une ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois représenter ce matin
madame la reporter cher mari mes chers
collègues je soutiens dans un premier
temps a salué la qualité du travail de
la commission des lois et de ce
rapporteur marie mercier ce texte
cosigné par plus de cent sénateurs et
sénatrices de tout bord politique
témoigne une nouvelle fois de la
capacité de notre assemblée à se saisir
de grands sujets de société
la proposition de loin que je présente
aujourd'hui devant vous est le fruit de
longs travaux menés par la délégation
aux droits des femmes que j'ai l'honneur
de présider
elle découle également d'une conviction
la conviction que notre droit pénal
actuel ne protège pas suffisamment les
enfants contre les prédateurs sexuels
plusieurs études montrent que les
mineurs représentent la classe d'âge la
plus exposée aux violences sexuelles
40% des viols et tentatives de viols
déclarés concernent des enfants de moins
de 15 ans 27% de ses crimes touche des
enfants de moins de 10 ans il y aurait
chaque année en france environ 150000
viols et tentatives de viols sur mineure
soit c'est à dire 300 à 400 par jour
pour ajouter à l'inacceptable les crimes
sexuels sur mineurs présente une
caractéristique spécifique dans
l'immense majorité des cas le
mis-en-cause connaissait sa victime
neuf fois sur dix le prédateur sexuel
est un proche un ami un membre de la
famille une personne de confiance
ces chiffres effroyables nous le savons
sont en dessous de la réalité
il témoigne de l'ampleur de ce phénomène
et nous impose d'agir pour protéger les
jeunes mineurs et condamner leurs
auteurs ce texte n'a pas été élaborée en
réaction à la déflagration politique et
médiatique provoqué par le livre de
camille kouchner la familia grande et
mais ce livre un fait écho à la
proposition loi et offre aux
législateurs l'opportunité de se
positionner de façon claire
si notre rôle n'est pas de réagir de
manière impulsive aux soubresauts de
l'actualité
il est en revanche de notre devoir de
prendre en compte et d'accompagner les
élèves et les évolutions profondes de
notre société car nous le savons les
représentants ce les représentations
sociétale de ces violences sexuelles ont
fluctué au cours du temps et les travaux
sur la psychologie des jeunes
adolescents et sur la notion de
consentement chez l'enfant sont
désormais légion dans ce domaine il faut
le reconnaître notre droit n'a pas
évolué à la même vitesse que nos
consciences
au terme des travaux de la délégation
j'ai acquis une conviction celle qu'un
enfant ne dispose jamais du discernement
suffisant pour consentir de manière
éclairée un rapport sexuel avec un
adulte l'instauration d'un seuil d'âge
de non consentement
apparaît alors comme étant une réponse
pertinente pour protéger les jeunes
mineurs en raison de leur particulière
vulnérabilité en raison de leur
inclination à se soumettre à l'autorité
de l'adulte c'était d'ailleurs le sens
des annonces faites en 2017 par le
président de la république qui
souhaitait instaurer un seuil d'âge à 15
ans le gouvernement avait cependant fait
marche arrière à la suite des réserves
émises par le conseil d'état sur la
constitutionnalité de la mesure
ses réserves dans pêche pas plus de deux
ans après la publication de cet avis de
réouvrir le débat sur ce seuil d'âge la
création d'une infraction nouvelles de
crimes sexuels sur mineure de 13 ans
balaye les objections invoqué à l'époque
d'une part parce qu'elle s'appuyait
principalement sur le choix de l'âge
retenu par le projet de loi 15 ans et
d'autre part quatre cette nouvelle
proposition de loi sur montrent la
difficulté liée à l'introduction d'une
présomption irréfragable de contraintes
réputé inconstitutionnelle en droit
pénal
en effet ce texte ne pose pas de
présomption de contrainte mais un tour
d'hui dans notre droit
un nouvel interdit celui de tout rapport
sexuel
avec un mineur de 13 ans il s'agit donc
aujourd'hui de poser une limite claire à
travers la création d'une nouvelle
infraction distincte de celle du crime
du viol les critères constitutifs du
crime du violent que sont la contrainte
la menace la violence ou la surprise
reviennent à faire porter l'appréciation
du juge ou du juré sur le comportement
de la victime et donc conduisent
fatalement à se poser la question de son
consentement
or la notion de consentement déjà
complexe lorsque la victime est un
adulte n'a tout simplement pas sa place
dans le débat
lorsque la victime est particulièrement
jeune l'élément intentionnel de ce
nouveau crime résultera de la
pénétration sexuelle ainsi que de la
connaissance de l'âge de la victime par
l'auteur des faits pour se défendre
l'auteur aura la possibilité d'apporter
la preuve qu'ils ne pouvaient connaître
l'âge du mineur avec lequel il a eu une
relation sexuelle
ce nouveau crime serait punie de vingt
ans de réclusion criminelle
à l'instar de la peine prévue pour le
viol avec circonstances aggravantes
avec ce texte on ne questionne plus le
comportement de l'enfant mais celui de
l'adulte
les tergiversations autour du
comportement de l'enfant ne pourront
plus des douanes et l'agresseur de sa
pleine et entière responsabilité pénale
l'une des difficultés qui nous restaient
à surmonter était la critique portée par
certains sur le déficit de protection
qui frapperait une victime mineure ayant
entre 13 et 15 ans du fait de la
création de cette infraction spécifique
les travaux menés par notre rapporteur
marie mercier ont permis dès l'examen du
texte en commission de faire disparaître
ces critiques en prévoyant que pour une
victime ayant entre 13 et 15 ans la
contrainte morale ou la surprise peuvent
également résulter de ce que la victime
mineure est âgée de moins de 15 ans et
ne disposait pas de la maturité sexuelle
suffisante
mes chers collègues cette proposition de
loi permettra de franchir un cap
juridique mais aussi
oaktree nal en adoptant cette loi vous
permettrait non seulement de renforcer
notre arsenal législatif en faveur d'une
meilleure protection des mineurs mais
vous permettrait aussi et surtout
d'entériner un virage majeur dans la
manière d'appréhender ces agissements un
oeuf
un enfant ne sera alors jamais plus
considérés comme complices ou
complaisant vis-à-vis des actes sexuels
qu'un adulte comme est sur lui le seul
et unique responsable sera son auteur
l'agresseur ce changement aura un impact
essentiel dans la reconstruction future
des enfants frappés par cette ignominie
permettre à la justice de reconnaître
intégralement leur statut de victime et
permettre aussi aux enfants devenus
adultes de leur ôter le poids d'une
culpabilité est prouvée à tort monsieur
le garde des sceaux
la haute-assemblée vous propose
aujourd'hui une évolution importante du
droit pénal mais il n'y a pas qu'au
sénat a que les choses bougent
en effet vous avez sûrement récemment
reçu le rapport de notre collègue député
alexandra louis qui elle aussi plaide
pour la création d'une nouvelle
infraction spécifique
doit-on y voir les prémices d'une
évolution qui pourrait être soutenu par
le groupe majoritaire à l'assemblée
nationale si tel était le cas
monsieur le ministre nous faisant nous
invitons solennellement le gouvernement
à se saisir du texte qui va être je
l'espère très largement adopté par le
sénat et à l'inscrire très rapidement à
l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée nationale
comme l'a mentionné notre collègue
dominique vais rien à l'instant la haute
assemblée sera particulièrement
vigilante sur ce point il ne faudrait
pas que vous veniez nous voir dans
quelques mois avec un nouveau texte qui
proposerait la même chose mais pas avec
les mêmes auteurs car monsieur le garde
des sceaux
lorsque j'entends l'ancien secrétaire
d'état à l'égalité
marlène schiappa proposé ces derniers
jours d'instaurer un seuil d'âge alors
qu'elle s'y était engagé en 2017 et ne
l'avait fait
ne l'avait pas fait en 2018 dans le
cadre de son projet de loi
permettez moi de sourire mais de sourire
jaune le sénat a malheureusement déjà eu
à subir cela depuis le début de cette
législature
nous avons aujourd'hui la possibilité d'
impulser un nouveau paradigme et de
lever l'ambiguïté persistantes autour du
consentement de l'enfant
saisissons nous de cette chance trop
d'enfants souffrent de n'avoir pas su
trop d'enfants souffrent de n'avoir pas
pu en votant cette proposition de loi
nous portons la voix des enfants et nous
pouvons dire simplement non ceci est un
crime
merci merci cercueil
[Applaudissements]
dans la suite de la discussion la parole
est à madame marie mercier rapporteur de
la commission des lois pour dix minutes
si madame la présidente messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues à
l'occasion de l'examen de la proposition
de loi déposée par annie billon est pas
plusieurs de nos collègues du sénat est
à nouveau amené à se prononcer sur la
protection des mineurs contre les
violences sexuelles dont ils peuvent
être victimes de la part d'adultes
ce débat fait suite aux discussions
approfondies que nous savions en 2018
lors de l'examen de la loi chappe à
notre débat intervient également après
plusieurs travaux de contrôle du sénat
auquel j'ai participé le plus récent
étant la mission commune d'information
sur les politiques publiques de lutte
contre les violences sexuelles sur
mineures commises par des adultes dans
le cadre de leur métier ou leur fonction
notre collègue alice bilan souhaite
cependant franchir une autre étape en
introduisant dans le code pénal
une nouvelle infraction de crimes
sexuels sur mineurs qui seraient
constitués en cas de pénétration
sexuelle commise par un majeur sur un
mineur de 13 ans à la différence du viol
de l'agression sexuelle la fraction
serait constitué sans qu'il soit
nécessaire de rechercher s'il est un
élément de contrainte menace ou surprise
dont la preuve est souvent difficile à
rapporter
elle serait punie de vingt ans de
réclusion criminelle soit la même peine
que celle prévue en cas de viol sur
mineure de 15 ans en 2018 le sénat avait
déjà débattu de l'opportunité de créer
une telle infraction ou de modifier la
définition du viol afin d'introduire une
présomption de non consentement en
dessous d'un certain seuil d'âge à
l'époque notre commission n'avait pas
retenu ses propositions en raison des
doutes émis sur leur constitutionnalité
mais aussi en raison du risque de
l'intrus que l'introduction d'un nouveau
seuil à 13 ans n'affaiblisse la
protection due aux jeunes de 13 à 15 ans
la commission avait préféré compléter le
code pénal par des dispositions donc
applicable immédiatement
précisant le sens des mesures de
contrainte et de surprises
éléments constitutifs de l'infraction de
viol afin qu'il soit plus facile et les
caractériser elles peuvent résulter de
la différence d'âge entre la victime
l'auteur des faits ou résulter de l'abus
de la vulnérabilité de la victime ne
disposant pas du discernement nécessaire
pour six ans je voudrais souligner que
la proposition de loi de nos collègues
tire les leçons de ces débats de 2018
à l'époque le gouvernement avait
envisagé de modifier la définition du
viol pour introduire une présomption de
non consentement en compte en cas
d'actes de pénétrations sexuelles avec
un mineur de moins de 15 ans
cette solution n'avait pas été retenu au
regard de la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel qui n'admet en fait que
dans le domaine contraventionnelle la
possibilité de prévoir une présomption
en droit pénal et à condition qu'il
s'agisse d'une présomption simple en
fait la proposition de loi elle
contourne cet obstacle juridique en
créant une infraction autonome la
nouvelle infraction crimes sexuels sur
mineurs seraient construites sur le
modèle du délit d'atteinte sexuelle qui
figure déjà dans le code pénal qui punit
de sept ans de prison et 100 mille euros
damende le majeur qui a un contact de
nature sexuelles avec un mineur de moins
de 15 ans le crime sexuel sur mineur
viendrait renforcer la protection des
jeunes de moins de 13 ans le délit
d'atteinte sexuelle étant maintenue pour
les jeunes de 13 à 15 ans
dans son avis du 15 mars 2018 sur le
projet de la loi chapa le conseil d'état
avait par ailleurs estimé que la seule
référence à l'âge de la victime pourrait
ne pas suffire pour répondre à
l'exigence constitutionnelle relative à
un élément intentionnel
en matière criminelle le fait de retenir
un seul d'âge à 13 ans plutôt qu'à 15
ans réduit cependant ce risque
constitutionnel avec un seuil à 13 ans
l'écart d'âge avec un jeune majeur
devient plus significatif ce qui rend
beaucoup plus improbable que celui ci
puisse entretenir une relation consentie
avec un mineur à peine sortis de
l'enfance
ces considérations ont conduit la
commission a accepté la proposition de
loi considérant qu elle posa n'interdit
plus clair certes à la fois aux dires
ils sont 19
fort potentiel et c'est très bien mais
surtout pour moi en direction des
enfants qui doivent savoir que certains
actes commis sur eux par un adulte ne
sont pas autorisés et il faut le leur
dire
la sauvegarde de l'enfance passe par des
interdits le mineur l'enfant devient un
acteur c'est la loi qui interdit d'avoir
des rapports sexuels avec un adulte la
loi le protège la loi dit non c'est cet
interdit la qui doit s'ancrer chez
l'enfant l'éducation à là dessus un rôle
majeur à jouer et c'est la société tout
entière qui doit s'emparer de la
protection des mineurs pour changer les
mentalités
la commission a enrichi le texte d'abord
pour éviter les têtes qui pourraient
résulter de la création d'un nouveau
seuil d'âge pour moi l'âge c'est le
clair obscur de la réalité je suis
personnellement très soucieux d'éviter
que la fixation d'un seuil d'âge à 13
ans sous-entendent que tout d'un coup un
jeune de 13 ans et un jour serait
consentants
cela entraînerait alors un
affaiblissement de la protection que
nous devons aux jeunes de 13 à 15 ans
c'est pourquoi la commission introduit
sur mon initiative l'un arctique
additionnelles acceptées par une bille
on que le sénat avait déjà adopté en
2018 mais qui n'avait pas été retenu
dans la version définitive de la loi
schiappa afin d'indiquer dans le code
pénal que la contrainte éléments
constitutifs du viol peut résulter du
jeune âge du mineur de moins de 15 ans
qui ne disposait pas de la maturité
sexuelle suffisantes concernant le
dispositif même de la proposition
d'année billon la commission a apporté
deux améliorations plus techniques
visant notamment à préciser la
définition de la notion pénétration
sexuelle en l'alignant sur la définition
retenue pour le viol la commission aussi
procédé à une coordination avec le code
de procédure pénale afin d'appliquer aux
nouveaux crimes sexuels sur mineurs
les règles de procédure dérogatoire
prévue pour les affaires qui concernent
une mineure
je pense par exemple à la possibilité de
prononcer une injonction de soins afin
que l'auteur des faits soit suivie
médicalement par le jeu des renvois la
mesures que nous avons adoptées aura
également pour effet d'étendre à la
nouvelle infraction
la règle de prescription applicable aux
autres crimes sur mineurs
soit un délai de 30 ans à compter de la
majorité de la victime
il s'agit d'une règle très protectrice
puisque le délai de prescription de
droit commun et je vous rappelle de 20
ans à compter de la commission des faits
il tient compte du temps souvent très
long qui s'écoulent avant que la victime
ne parvient à briser la loi du silence
et trouve la force de porter plainte
la commission a également introduit un
volet préventif dans le texte
en adoptant plusieurs amendements
présentés par michel savin et valérie
boyer deux articles additionnels
concerne le fils y est ce qui est un
outil qui a fait ses preuves dans le
cadre des enquêtes judiciaires mais
aussi comme moyen de contrôler les
antécédents d'un individu avant de
l'embaucher pour un poste où il trouvera
un contact régulier les démineurs afin
d'exploiter encore mieux les
potentialités de ce fichier la
commission vous propose de compléter la
liste des infractions entraînant une
inscription au pij s est de prévoir une
inscription automatique pour les
infractions sur mineurs quelle que soit
la peine encourue
enfin nous avons adopté un amendement
qui vise à encourager les juridictions a
prononcé la peine complémentaire
d'interdiction d'exercer une activité
professionnelle sociale au contact de
mineurs afin de mieux prévenir la
récidive
je suis persuadé que l'examen du texte
en séance publique aujourd'hui permettra
de l'enrichir encore hier plusieurs
amendements ici de tous les maux on sue
ont reçu le soutien de la coalition
et j'espère qu'ils seront adoptées par
notre assemblée
j'ai déposé un amendement qui allonge le
délai de prescription du délit de non
dénonciation de mauvais traitement
agression ou atteint 6 la fille jeanne
prévue par l'article 434-3 du code pénal
afin que cette infraction deviennent
plus dissuasive et compte tenu du temps
souvent très lourds comme je les dis
qu'il s'écoule avant la révélation de
ces affaires vous proposons de porter le
délai de prescription à 10 ans à compter
de la majorité de la victime en cas de
délit et à 20 ans en cas de crime
la commission s'est également prononcé
en faveur d'un amendement déposé par nos
collègues du groupe socialistes
écologistes et républicains tendant à
créer une circonstance aggravante du
délit d'atteinte sexuelle sur mineure de
15 ans en cas d'inceste
il s'agit d'un sujet qui préoccupe
légitimement de concitoyens et sur
lequel nous devons progresser
la grande majorité des violences
sexuelles sur mineure ayant lieu et nous
le savons dans le cercle familial
la commission soutient enfin l'adoption
de deux amendements complémentaires qui
précise la définition du viol
celle du nouveau crime sexuel soit
mineur afin de viser l'ensemble des
actes bucco génitaux actuellement ces
actes sont pris en compte lorsque la
victime est un garçon mais pas lorsque
la victime est une petit fils cette
différence de traitement est
difficilement justifiable et méritent
d'être corrigés
je suis l'auteur de l'amendement au-delà
de ces modifications législatives
au delà des moyens accrus nécessaire
pour la justice et les tribunaux je suis
convaincu que c'est une mobilisation de
la société tout entière et je le redis
qui est nécessaire pour faire reculer
les violences sexuelles sur mineurs et
l'omerta qui les entourent trop souvent
l'actualité nous rappelle qu'aucun
milieu social n'était pas renié et que
les agressions se produisent
majoritairement dans le cadre familial
l'examen de cette proposition de loi
constitue une étape supplémentaire dans
l'indispensable prise de conscience qui
est la clé d'une lutte efficace contre
ces violences inacceptables
ces violences sont les crimes contre
l'enfance les lois ne sont pas de pures
acte de puissance
ce sont des actes de sagesse de justice
et de raison et ses portes à l'iss si
nous le rappelle
merci marc à porter la suite de la
discussion la parole est un monsieur
eric dupond-moretti garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice
samedi
monsieur le président
madame la présidente de la délégation
aux droits des femmes madame a rapporté
à madame et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs
yat-il causes plus nobles dans notre
république cause plus juste cause
aujourd'hui plus urgente que celle
d'assurer pleinement après tant d'années
de dénis la protection de nos enfants
contre les crimes sexuels une prise de
conscience générale traversée interroge
la société tout entière et nous devons
c'est notre devoir y répondre
tous ensemble dans un vaste mouvement de
libération de la parole les victimes de
crimes sexuels et notamment d'inceste
sont de plus en plus nombreuses à faire
entendre leur voix la voix de leurs
souffrances
trop longtemps enfui trop longtemps
étouffé qui nous demandent d'agir pour
empêcher que d'autres enfants
connaissent à l'avenir le même cauchemar
il nous faut bien sûr saluer leur
courage leur apporter notre soutien leur
témoigner notre solidarité
mais il nous faut aussi à nous
parlementaires et gouvernement
rassemblés dans le même combat
donner une traduction juridique à ce
besoin de protections et de
reconnaissance
le crime doit être clairement nommés les
victimes pleinement reconnue et ses
objectifs partagés ne peuvent être
atteints nous avons tous cette
conviction que par une amélioration de
nos règles juridiques et de la réponse
judiciaire
les enfants abusés hier sont devenus des
adultes que les réseaux sociaux souvent
bien des années après ont aidé à révéler
leur histoire et à dire leur souffrance
des voix forte et puissante se sont
exprimés mais également avec elle est
souvent grâce à elle des milliers
d'anonymes cette libération nous le
savons va se poursuivre mais les réseaux
sociaux ne peuvent cependant pas
remplacer le besoin de justice toute
modification de la loi pénale doit être
envisagée avec détermination mais
prudents les évolutions de la loi pénale
doivent prendre en compte les phénomènes
sociaux mais elle doit s'accompagner
d'une réflexion aboutie notamment en
termes de prescription sans céder à la
précipitation capelle une émotion bien
légitime
vous le savez notre gouvernement a fait
de la protection des enfants une
priorité du quinquennat et nous sommes
convaincus que seule une action
collective est efficace c'est pourquoi
tous les ministères sont moment
c'est dans le plan porté par adrien tac
et de lutte contre les violences faites
aux enfants
cette mobilisation s'est déjà traduite
par l'adoption de la loi du 3 ou 2018
qui a renforcé notre droit dans la lutte
contre les infractions sexuelles
commises à l'égard des mineurs même si
nous devons aller plus loin je voudrais
rappeler les améliorations récentes
apportées par le législateur et qui sont
autant de références pour nos travaux le
délai de prescription
ainsi été allongé de 20 à 30 ans pour
les crimes sexuels commis sur les
mineurs délai courant à compter de la
majorité de la victime afin de laisser
davantage de temps à celle ci pour
porter plainte
les dispositions interprétative
immédiatement applicables aux procédures
en cours même pour des faits commis
avant la réforme ont clarifié la notion
de contrainte pour indiquer qu'elle peut
résulter de la différence d'âge
existante entre la victime et l'auteur
ainsi s'agissant du mineur victime âgée
de 15 ans ou 1
il est désormais précisé que la
contrainte morale ou la surprise sont
caractérisés par l'abus de la
vulnérabilité de la victime ne disposant
pas du discernement nécessaire pour ses
actes
cette loi a également prévu si le crime
de viol ne peut être établi que toute
pénétration sexuelle commise sur un
mineur de 15 ans par un majeurs
caractérisent le délit d'atteinte
sexuelle délit
qui je le rappelle est puni d'une peine
de sept ans d'emprisonnement et de dix
ans en cas de circonstances aggravantes
faut-il aller plus loin et sur quels
points
ce sont les questions qu'il nous faut
maintenant trancher
j'observe d'abord que les apports de la
réforme de 2018 sont très récents et que
même si un travail d'évaluation de
grande qualité a pu être mené par la
députée alexandra louis il n'est pas
possible aujourd'hui d'évaluer
pleinement le bénéfice de ces
dispositions
pour autant je vous rejoins madame la
sénatrice
nous devons collectivement visé
l'exigence d'un plus haut niveau de
protection des mineurs le texte que vous
examiner aujourd'hui retient toute
l'attention du gouvernement en ce qu'il
prévoit principalement de créer un crime
puni sans de 20 ans d'emprisonnement
tout acte de pénétration sexuelle commis
par une personne majeure sur un mineur
de 13 ans je tiens à cet égard a salué
l'implication de la présidente billon
ainsi que celle du groupe union
centriste qui a inscrit cette
proposition de loi
elle nous permet d'avoir un débat que
vous l'aurez compris j'estime essentiel
mais qui je vous l'indiquais d'emblée
devra à mon avis nourrir des
concertations dans les semaines à venir
ma responsabilité de garde des sceaux
consiste à soutenir le meilleur ma
responsabilité de garde des sceaux
consiste à soutenir le meilleur
dispositif tout en assurant le respect
des exigences de notre état de droit les
attentes des victimes sont trop fortes
pour risquer la déception et
l'incompréhension d'une réforme qui
pourrait donner lieu à une censure
constitutionnelle des questions
importantes restent posées et le rapport
de la commission ne les occulte
d'ailleurs pas j'observe que le seul
criminel retenus dans la nouvelle
écriture proposé est celui de 13 ans là
où la loi du 3 août 2010 8 retenait le
seuil de 15 ans votre proposition
pourrait ainsi être perçu comme un
affaiblissement de la protection des
mineurs de 13 à 15 ans emilie a à tout
le moins une question d'articulation
[Applaudissements]
la parole est aux ministres par ailleurs
le par ailleurs le crime que vous
proposait d'instituer ne porte pas le
nom de viol tout en étant puni comme tel
des associations ont déjà alerté sur
l'importance attachée à une dénomination
criminels clair au risque sinon de
l'incompréhension et 2 la confusion
enfin s'il n'est pas interdit de faire
coexister plusieurs régimes juridiques
puisque votre proposition ne pourrait
concerner que les faits commis après son
entrée en vigueur at-on véritablement
mesurer la difficulté pour les
magistrats et les jurés qui aurait
appliqué plusieurs régimes juridiques en
fonction de la date de commission des
faits madame la présidente billon je
salue votre proposition de loi comme une
contribution importante au débat
démocratique que nous devons avoir sur
ce sujet cette proposition reçoit un
accueil favorable de la part du
gouvernement mais nous devons en
s'appuyant sur cette base
comme sur les autres propositions et
travaux existants je pense notamment aux
textes et rapport de madame la sénatrice
rossignol et de mesdames les députés
louis et santiago parfaire le dispositif
envisagé et le sécuriser juridiquement
nous souhaitons compléter le travail
normatif à la lumière de nos débats on
vous y associant étroitement mais aussi
dans la concertation indispensable avec
les associations qui participent au
quotidien de la libération de la parole
et à la prise en charge et à la défense
des victimes et je vais engager dès la
semaine prochaine
ce travail de
citation avec adrien te mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs vous l'aurez
compris nous partageons votre combat
celui en faveur d'une protection accrue
des mineurs contre les violences
sexuelles
votre combat est aussi le mien celui
d'adrien taquet et du gouvernement tout
entier et vous pouvez compter sur notre
engagement pour avancer très rapidement
à vos côtés merci monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues il est 11 heures
passées le scrutin est clos pour
l'élection d'un juge suppléant à la cour
de justice de la république dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur adrien taquet secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'enfance et des familles
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des lois
madame la présidente de la délégation
aux droits des femmes annie guillon
madame les rapporteurs marie mercier
labs et messieurs les sénateurs
si nous avons ce débat aujourd'hui c'est
parce que depuis plus de trente ans les
femmes et des hommes anonymes ou non ont
le courage de briser le silence et de
parler evatt au marbre
janice bombardier flavie flament
christine angot sarah abitbol andrea
bescond la nsa springer à camille
kouchner
angélique céline christine laetitia
melinda sabrina tout pensionnaires parmi
nombreux autres de la maison d'accueil
jean bru agents si nous avons ce débat
aujourd'hui c'est parce que des femmes
et des hommes à la tête de leurs
associations crient sans relâche depuis
des années les chiffres indigne des
violences faites à nos enfants en
particulier des violences sexuelles
qu'ils subissent je pense évidemment
isabelle aubry 2 face à l'inceste à
françois de vaux de la parole libérée
laurent boyer arnaud galets l'ensemble
des associations de protection de
l'enfance comme la voix de l'enfant ou
encore l'enfant bleu et toutes les
autres si nous avons ce débat
aujourd'hui c'est parce que des
professionnels pédiatres psychiatres
anthropologue philosophe travaille
depuis des années pour mettre à jour les
ressorts profonds les mécanismes intimes
mais aussi structurelles qui rendent
possible ce qui n'est rien d'autre qu'un
phénomène de masse dorothée du si
évidemment muriel salmona marc crépon ou
encore l'ensemble des chercheurs qui au
sein du cnrs à la demande de laurence
rossignol avait travaillé sur le sujet
en 2017 si nous avons ce débat
aujourd'hui c'est parce que nous le
devons aux dizaines de milliers
d'anonymes qui depuis quelques jours ont
le courage de parler pour que plus
jamais ne s'installe le déni et le
silence si nous avons ce débat
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il dépasse
plus que jamais largement l'enceinte de
cet hémicycle qui n'interroge pas
simplement notre droit ou
nos politiques publiques mais bien
chacun d'entre nous individuellement et
nous tous collectivement en tant que
peuple en tant que nation qui accepte
que ses enfants subissent tant de
violence et qui laisse nombre d'entre
eux mourir à petit feu
notre société tout entière doit cesser
de mimer le silence comme le dit
symboliquement dorothée du si dans son
ouvrage le berceau des dominations nous
devons collectivement briser la
grammaire du silence et de la domination
nous devons interroger nos systèmes de
valeurs interroger la famille non pas
pour la détruire
elle est forte heureusement encore
largement le lieu de l'épanouissement et
de l'amour
mais reconnaître qu'elle puisse être le
lieu de la violence et de l'exil pour un
certain nombre d'enfants briser ces
fameux secret de famille si délétère
interrogé aussi probablement le modèle
patriarcal sur lequel notre société
s'est construite
alors depuis 30 ans les déflagrations
son sont nombreuses mais à chaque fois
le couvercle se referme
depuis 30 ans néanmoins les
déflagrations sont de plus en plus
rapprochées de plus en plus forte et il
faut y voir je pense un motif d'espoir
société supporte de moins en moins là
supportable notre société refuse de
détourner le regard des actes commis
derrière ces portes closes dans
l'exercice de mes fonctions avec
l'ensemble du gouvernement
nous avons très tôt voulu faire de
l'écouté du soutien aux victimes un
aspect central de l'action
le plan de lutte contre les violences
faites aux enfants évoquée par le garde
des sceaux que j'avais présenté en
novembre 2019 à l'occasion du 30e
anniversaire de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
mais était justement l'accent sur
l'importance d'accompagner ceux qui
avaient traversé ces épreuves ce sont 22
mesures travailler avec l'ensemble des
associations à l'époque des
professionnels la protection de
l'enfance et de la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles avec l'ensemble des
ministres du gouvernement
elle était forte elle commença à
produire leurs effets
avec le garde des sceaux eric
dupond-moretti nous formons désormais
mieux les magistrats pour qu'il soit
pleinement en mesure de traiter ces
situations et c'est affaire de violences
sexuelles subies par les enfants
nous déployons les unités d'accueil
pédiatrique enfance en danger qui situés
dans les services pédiatriques des
hôpitaux permettent d'accueillir dans un
lieu sécurisé en protecteur des mineurs
victimes de violences de violences
sexuelles parfois deux trois quatre ans
et de recueillir leurs paroles par des
professionnels policiers et gendarmes
formés on recueil de la parole de
l'enfant
notre territoire rencontra un par
département d'ici 2022 nous avons
renforcé le contrôle des antécédents
judiciaires des personnels qui
interviennent au contact des enfants et
systématiser les vérifications du fis
ges le fameux fichier des agresseurs
sexuels
nous avons vous avez par votre vote en
août dernier durci les peines pour les
personnes qui consultent des sites pédo
criminelle portant la peine encourue de
2 à 5 ans et emportant ainsi inscription
automatique au fichier des agresseurs
sexuels de ces personnes qui ne pourront
plus jamais travailler au contact des
enfants
ce n'était pas le cas jusqu'à votre vote
d'août dernier
nous avons également systématiser les
bilans psychologiques
la prise en charge des victimes afin de
les aider dès les premiers pas et sur le
long cours sur un chemin de de soins
tous ensemble nous réagissons mais ce
que nous montre sans artifice
l'actualité ce que nous dit sans fard
les victimes ce que nous savons au fond
de nous mêmes c'est que nous devons
aller plus loin nous devons aller plus
vite nous devons franchir une nouvelle
étape
nous le devons non seulement aux
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
ont témoigné ces derniers jours mais
aussi aux millions d'autres qui n'ont
pas encore réussi à le faire
le sénat comme l'assemblée nationale
entende bien évidemment cet appel est
l'initiative dans l'examen nous
rassemblent aujourd'hui le montre bien
et nous ne pouvons que le saluer jeu
salut à mon tour en particulier le
travail constant de la délégation aux
droits des femmes et le travail
également de marie mercier de michel
meunier de dominique c'est rien c'est
ces dernières années ça lui aussi à
cette occasion le travail effectué par
la députée alexandra louis sommes
convaincus que nous devons encore mieux
formés et mieux sensibiliser très
largement aux questions de violence
sexuelle faite aux enfants
instaurer une véritable culture de
prévention partagé par l'ensemble des
professionnels qui sont au contact des
enfants
mais nous devons aussi avancé bien plus
rapidement sur la sensibilisation des
enfants eux mêmes afin qu'ils deviennent
les premiers remparts aux menaces qui
pèsent sur eux comme c'est le cas dans
d'autres pays
je pense à la suède je pense au canada
et nous avons engagé avec jean michel
blanquer des travaux pour renforcer et
déployer ces temps indispensable pour
sensibiliser mais aussi pour prévenir et
repérer toute forme de violence envers
nos enfants nous devons aussi évidemment
mieux prendre en charge les victimes
envers qui la dette de la collectivité
n'a pas de prix estimées comme cela a
été trop longtemps le cas qu'elles
peuvent se remettre seul du traumatisme
qu'elles ont vécu est une seconde forme
de violence qui leur est faite
le coût individuel est inimaginable pour
qu'il ne le vis pas et le coût collectif
est phénoménal quand on sait aujourd'hui
que les violences sexuelles subis dans
l'enfance sont le premier facteur de
tentatives de suicide de dépression de
troubles du comportement alimentaire de
maladies chroniques à l'âge adulte
alors parmi toutes les questions qui
nourrissent le débat public il y à celle
de l'âge du consentement sur laquelle le
sénat a souhaité par ce texte proposé
une évolution le garde des sceaux s'est
exprimé très clairement à ce sujet et a
très justement pointé les défis que
soulève cette notion et les différents
aspects du texte la concertation évoquée
par le garde des sceaux doit permettre
de répondre à tous ces défis à toutes
ces questions et enrichir encore les
dispositions de cette proposition de loi
et des débats que nous allons avoir ce
matin elle sera elle sera rapide car les
données les sujets sont sur la table
elle sera efficace elle sera large elle
fera large dans la diversité des paroles
qu elle recueillera elle
sera à l'image de ce que nous sommes à
l'az l'image de ce à quoi nous faisons
face tous ensemble mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs ce ne sont pas seulement
les victimes qui nous attendent
c'est la société tout entière qui nous
regardent c'est probablement même une
introspection individuelle et collective
que nous unissions aujourd'hui tous
ensemble
ce ne sera pas aisé nous devrons
remettre en cause un certain nombre de
nos réflexes de nos modèles de nos
références
ça nous interrogera toutes et tous mais
il faut en passer par là mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs j'en suis
convaincu nous devons appréhender ce
sujet de la violence sexuelles sur les
enfants dans toute son entièreté dans
toute sa complexité
allez dans les replis que nous n'avons
pas encore exploré et qui ne sont pas
encore dans le débat public
nous devons nous assurer que la parole
de celles et ceux qui ne peuvent pas
parler pourra s'exprimer et je pense
notamment aux enfants en situation de
handicap qui comme vous le savez comme
s'agissant des femmes face aux violences
conjugales sont bien plus exposées à ces
menaces ne pas y faire face ne s'est
passé à côté d'une partie importante du
sujet ce cheminement ne sera pas simple
il sera même douloureux il sera
douloureux individuellement et
collectivement
mais nous devons le faire pour le bien
de nos enfants d'aujourd'hui et de
demain et probablement aussi un peu pour
nous mêmes je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre dans la suite
de la discussion générale l'apport
l'état monsieur xavier iacovelli pour le
groupe rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants pour 4
minutes hommes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres madame la rapporteure chers
collègues
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
s'inscrit dans un contexte politique et
médiatique particulier où la parole des
victimes se libère peu à peu enfin
mettant fin à l'omerta qui règne trop
souvent à cela s'ajoute une récente
décision de la cour d'appel de
versailles du 12 novembre dernier
rejetant une demande de requalification
de vent violent de faits présumés
d'atteintes sexuelles commis sur une
jeune fille de 14 ans siné jamais
opportun de légiférer sous le coup de
l'émotion ou suite à un fait divers
ni de remettre en cause le fils du juge
notre assemblée ne peut rester muette
face à ces débats sociétaux qui traverse
notre pays en particulier lorsqu'il
s'agit de la protection des enfants
nous savons les jeunes mineurs sont
particulièrement exposés aux violences
sexuelles
puisque 60 % de celles qui sont recensés
concernent les mineurs dans leur rapport
sur la loi du 3 août 2010 8 nos
collègues députés erwan balanant et
marie-pierre rixin avait juin à juste
titre estimé que le seuil des 13 ans
marquer la limite indiscutable de
l'enfance si la notion de consentement
trouve déjà sa complexité lorsque le
plaignant est un adulte
celle ci un acte à un écho très
particulier et très singulier lorsque la
victime est un jeune mineur c'est
pourquoi la proposition de loi vise à
introduire au sein du code pénal
un nouveau crime puni de vingt ans de
réclusion criminelle est caractérisée
par tout acte de pénétration sexuelle de
quelque nature qu'il soit commis par une
personne majeure sur un mineur de 13 ans
notre assemblée a connu déjà ce débat et
le gouvernement s'est saisi de cette
question à l'occasion de la loi de 2018
qui par une disposition interprétative
est venu préciser
l'appréciation de la contrainte et de la
surprise éléments constitutifs du viol
et des autres agressions sexuelles afin
d'en faciliter la démonstration par le
juge lorsque la victime est un mineur de
moins de 15 ans le texte que nous
examinons aujourd'hui emprunter un autre
chemin plus affirmée encore en proposant
de criminaliser tous les actes de
pénétration sur mineur de moins
13 en rappelant ainsi qu'en dessous de
cet âge l'enfant est incapable de
discernement pour consentir à ce type de
rapport avec un adulte affirmant qu'en
dessous de cet âge
la question de la violence de la
contrainte de la menace ou de la
surprise ne doit pas intervenir
posant finalement un interdit clair dans
la loi plus ferme que le délit
d'atteinte sexuelle sur mineur de 15 ans
je tiens à saluer le travail de la
rapporteure marie mercier qui a
contribué à l'enrichissement de ce texte
par l'adoption de plusieurs amendements
en commission à son objectif était
notamment de ne pas induire par l'âge de
13 ans une moindre protection des
mineurs de 13 à 15 ans si l'articulation
de la disposition introduite à cette fin
avec les dispositions interprétative
issus des lois chapa peut poser question
l'objectif de ne pas minorer la
protection des autres mineurs et
justifié la question de l'âge et des
effets de seuil et centrale et des
travaux sont en cours à l'assemblée
nationale nous avons tous à l'esprit
notamment avec le rapport d'alexandra
louis où la ppl santiago et la
concertation annoncée par le garde des
sceaux aujourd'hui donc plusieurs
questions retenir un seuil de 13 ans
assorti d'une disposition interprétatif
pour les 13 15 ans ou inclure tous les
mineurs de moins de 15 ans en ménageant
les causes de objective
d'irresponsabilité ces questions se
posent légitimement en droit comme une
opportunité
d'autres réflexions d'actualité sur
l'inceste ou sur la prescription enjeux
complexes qui peut être déterminant pour
la libération de la parole des victimes
vont mobiliser notre hémicycle ce matin
alors dans sa très grande majorité
écrasante majorité les membres du groupe
r dpi votera ce texte
à titre personnel et au regard est
rejoint par plusieurs de mes collègues
nous voterons également l'amendement
présenté par laurence rossignol portant
à quinze ans le seuil d'âge de la
nouvelle infraction créée je veux enfin
salué le travail de
l'auteur de cette proposition a ni
billon qui se saisit d'une un débat de
société majeur que nous pouvons je le
crois écarté d'un revers de main merci
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
l'audition la parole est à madame maryse
carrère pour l'europe et rds pour 4
minutes je maryse monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres madame la
rapporteure madame l'auteur de la
proposition de loi me chers collègues
l'enfance devrait toujours être le temps
de l'insouciance mais malheureusement
trop d'enfants subissent humiliation
violences physiques ou sexuelles
autant de traumatisme profond et durable
auquel il est inconcevable que la
société ne répondent pas ce soutien
inconditionnel est avant tout
indispensable pour que ces victimes
puissent se construire ou se
reconstruire en surmontant l'innommable
car face aux crimes sexuels la réponse
institutionnelle doit d'abord être celle
de la protection du mineur victime ce
sujet semble faire consensus dans sa
finalité
un adulte n'a pas à entretenir un
rapport une relation sexuelle avec un
enfant et il ne fait aucun doute qu'un
mineur de 13 ans est un enfant quel que
soit l'image qu'ils te renvoyer
nous ne pouvons pas à trouver des
positions parfois ambigu de certains
commentateurs discutant de l'attitude de
l'enfant victime
cherchant une forme de réciprocité
déculpabilisante pour l'adulte là où
nous devrions voir qu'une perversion du
besoin affectif de l'enfant
un enfant n'est pas un adulte à l'adulte
de le savoir et de s'y tenir
un adulte doit savoir se contrôler et
sans péché comme le disait camus dans
l'homme révolté
aussi je ne doute pas que nous devrions
arriver à une unanimité quant à la
prohibition des rapports des relations
sexuelles entre adultes et enfants et
cette unanimité ne devra pas être perdus
de vue quand nous débattrons des moyens
d'y parvenir car cette proposition
permis une avancée majeure pour notre
arsenal répressif et et je remercie
annick billon et l'ensemble des
signataires de cette proposition de loi
ainsi que marie mercier qui notre
rapporteur qui enrichit aussi le texte
elle pose un interdit claires et
strictes à travers la création d'une
infraction autonome interdisant sans
détour majeur d'avoir une relation
sexuelle avec mineure de 13 ans il est
nécessaire que notre droit puis se
répondre avec fermeté et sans complexité
à ces abus nous saluons donc l'ensemble
des dispositions de ce texte tant pour
leurs solutions apportées en vue de
faciliter la répression des faits
incriminés que pour leur respect de nos
principes fondamentaux en heurtant ne
retenant ni l'imprescriptibilité ni les
riffs rock habilité toutefois cette
évolution ne signifie pas que tout est
en chair régler d'abord nous devons
réfléchir aux moyens de protéger avec la
même efficacité
les enfants de 13 à 15 ans afin qu'il
n'y ait pas d'effets de seuil au delà à
la date d'anniversaire dean de mineurs
victimes
certes cette proposition apporte une
première réponse en disposant que la
contrainte morale ou la surprise peuvent
également résulter de ce que la victime
mineure étaient âgés de moins de 15 ans
et ne disposez pas de la maturité
sexuelle suffisante
nous devrons donc observer comment les
juges s'approprieront cette disposition
cette notion de maturité sexuelle
suffisante sans non plus nous empêcher
de poursuivre nos réflexions en vue de
perfectionner encore davantage ses
mécanismes ensuite il demeure la
question de l'inceste et de sa
condamnation pénale
le cas de l'abus sexuel entre familiale
n'est pas à ce jour l'objet d'une
répression suffisante
le code pénal ne l'envisagent creux
comme une sur qualification ou une
circonstance aggravante
certes la loi du 3 août 2010 8 a permis
d'avancer sur ce point mais le
dispositif pourrait être complété à
l'initiative de notre ancien collègue
françoise aborde le groupe rdse avait
déposé une proposition de résolution
visant à engager ce diverses mesures
pour intensifier la lutte et la
prévention contre l'inceste
je renouvelle donc notre souhait que des
réflexions soient poursuivis sur cette
question en scène et c'est peut-être le
plus important il faut observer que
l'arsenal répressif même le plus
perfectionné ne suffira pas à faire
cesser les abus la loi pénale ne fait
pas tout il faut aussi oeuvré pour une
meilleure sensibilisation de la société
sur ces sujets sans les enfants
abandonnée aux accès qui peuvent être
observés dans les réseaux sociaux il est
aussi nécessaire devenir un meilleur
accompagnement des victimes ainsi qu'à
un meilleur suivi médical des auteurs
des auteurs des actes pour cela au delà
des sens des seules sanctions nous
devons travailler à soutenir aider
davantage les professionnels des
services de protection à l'enfance
faisant face à ces situations
particulièrement lourde
d'un point de vue émotionnel et délicate
dans leur suivi toutes ces remarques ne
lève rien mon texte que nous discutons
et au sujet duquel le groupe rds se
montre favorable sans réserve
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
dans la suite de la discussion la parole
est à la présidente eliane assassi pour
le groupe sert ce pour quatre minutes
joyal monsieur le président je vous
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi de notre
collègue annick billon qui nous est
aujourd'hui soumise prend une résonance
particulière à l'aune de la qualité et
des révélations de camille kouchner des
révélations qui ont conduit comme il y a
trois ans de cela avec la sphère orange
stein a libéré la parole et à des
révélations plus large et universelle
sur les réseaux sociaux derrière le
hashtag mitu inceste
cette fois voici comment des drames
personnels
expurgé des secrets des cellules
familiales et des livres et du sceau
tacite du silence mène à l'éclosion de
sujet jusque là encore tabous de notre
société car même si la prescription des
faits est souvent de mise dans les
affaires d'inceste la libération de la
parole travaillera ce que ces
comportements soient si non bannie au
moins dénoncés pour ce qu'ils sont et
considéré pour ce qu'ils sont des
interdits structurant de la société
l'objet de la proposition de loi qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui n'est pas sans
lien avec cette problématique
puisqu'elle vise à poser un interdit
clair dans la loi l'interdiction absolue
de tout acte sexuel entre une personne
majeure et un mineur de moins de 13 ans
en instaurant dans le code pénal
une nouvelle infraction autonome cette
proposition de loi issue de l'actualité
- récente mais
moins sordides de la terre julie
présente selon nous deux éléments
importants qui la rendent valable est
recevable
premièrement sur les droits de la
défense et le respect du principe de
présomption d'innocence pour se défendre
de cette infraction autonome
l'auteur des faits aurait la possibilité
d'apporter la preuve qu'ils ne pouvaient
connaître l'âge exact du mineur avec
lequel il a eu une relation sexuelle ce
qui vient répondre aux risques
d'inconstitutionnalité soulevée
notamment par le conseil d'état dans son
avis sur le premier tech du gouvernement
en 2018 qui visait une présomption de
non consentement irréfragable
deuxièmement la question du seuil d'âge
à 13 ans juridiquement cela est pour
nous cohérent avec la présomption de non
responsabilité pénale des mineurs fixé à
13 ans dans le futur code de justice
pénale des mineurs
d'un point de vue sociétal cela est
également cohérent avec le fait qu'une
relation puisse être entretenue elle en
train une mineure de 15 ans et un une
jeune majeur de 18 ou 19 ans enfin l'âge
de 13 ans représente le seuil barrière
infranchissable du monde de l'enfance en
outre le texte a dit billon a été
enrichie en commission des lois
notamment grâce à un amendement de la
rapporteure dont je salue la finesse et
la précision du travail qui précise la
définition du viol en indiquant que la
contrainte morale ou la surprise de la
surprise éléments constitutifs de
l'infraction peuvent résulter de ce que
la victime mineure et est âgée de moins
de 15 ans ne disposez pas de la maturité
sexuelle suffisante
cette nouvelle indication est pour nous
bienvenue et prend en compte la
difficulté d'un seuil die d'un seul
d'âge d'un seuil des vieillards un
francis infranchissable fait des
maturités variable d'un adolescent à
l'autre cela dit une fois les points
positifs qui emporteront pour notre
groupe
un vote en faveur de cette proposition
de loi nous ne pouvons considérer la
création d'une infraction autonome aussi
légitime soit elle comme une réponse
suffisante à ce fléau des violences
sexuelles commises à l'encontre des
mineurs tout le volet préventif doit
être soulevée d'urgence en parallèle en
traitant les problématiques
tél la question telle que pardon la
question de la prévention et de
l'éducation sexuelle dès le plus jeune
âge
la question de la formation des
professionnels de l'enfance ou encore la
question des moyens de la justice et de
nos forces de l'ordre mais aussi des
moyens accordés au pays mis au monde de
l'enfant dans son ensemble de manière
générale ces infractions sont la
résurgence d'un modèle sociétal
millénaire celui de stéréotypes
archaïque et de la domination
patriarcale qui continue à sévir
malgré l'évolution des moeurs et des
lois à l'encontre des femmes et des
enfants
et c'est pourquoi il apparaît nécessaire
qu'une délégation aux droits des enfants
prennent sa place toute sa place au sein
de notre parlement
c'est ce que nous proposerons de nouveau
au cours du débat même si notre âme en
on a été jugée irrecevable
je vous remercie merci ma présidente et
chers collègues nous allons interrompre
quelques instants cette discussion
générale pour vous donner le résultat du
scrutin pour l'élection d'un juge
suppléant à la cour de justice de la
république
nombre de votants 131 non suffrages
exprimés 127 bulletins blancs trois
bulletins nuls 1 a obtenu madame marie
arlette carlotti 127 voix
madame marie arlette carlotti et obtenu
la majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés est proclamée jje suppléante la
cour de justice de la république et je
la félicite
c'est pour elle un jour particulier non
seulement pour cette belle élection mais
aussi pour son anniversaire et donc je
lui souhaite un joyeux anniversaire au
nom du sénat et en votre nom à tous
madame marie arlette carlotti juge
suppléante à la cour de justice de la
république va être appelé à prêter
serment devant le sénat
ce serment est prévue par l'article 2 de
la loi organique du 23 novembre 1993 sur
la cour de justice de la république
je vais donner lecture de la formule du
serment je prie la juge
suppléante de bien vouloir se lever à
l'appel de son nom et de répondre en
levant la main droite par les mots je le
jure
voici la formule du serment je jure et
promet de bien et fidèlement remplir mes
fonctions de garder le secret des
délibérations et des votes et de me
conduire en tout comme un digne et loyal
magistrat
madame marie arlette carlotti juge
suppléante
je le jure merci acte est donné par le
sénat du serment qui vient d'être prêté
devant lui mes chers collègues nous
reprenons la discussion générale de
cette proposition de loi
la parole est à madame dominique vien
pour le groupe union centriste pour six
minutes
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres madame la rapporteure 13 ans
ça c est trop peu pour protéger les
enfants mais de quoi parlons nous
aujourd'hui nous parlons de la création
d'un crime qui consiste pour un majeur à
avoir une relation sexuelle avec un
mineur le seul fait que la relation
sexuelle soit constatée et que le majeur
connaissent las de l'enfant suffit à
établir le crime et a envoyé l'adulte
passé ces vingt prochaines années
derrière les barreaux
la création de ce crime revient donc à
formaliser une véritable interdiction
pour un majeur d'avoir une relation
sexuelle avec un mineur de 13 ans et
moins
non seulement c'est compréhensible mais
c'est souhaitable
imaginez un adulte c'est à dire une
personne de plus de 18 ans avec un
enfant de moins de 13 ans très
majoritairement impubère est choquant et
choquant de la même façon de voir deux
jeunes dont un serait juste en dessous
de ses 15 ans et d'autres juste au
dessus de ses 18 ans
ils sont consentants me répondrez-vous
mais la loi
cette nouvelle loi que nous sommes en
train de voter elle se contrefiche du
consentement et c'est bien pour cela que
nous la voterons pour qu'on arrête
d'interroger le consentement du mineur
et le mineur de 13 ans avec ce nouveau
crime est victime sans avoir à le
prouver et c'est bien il est victime de
l'adulte et c'est à l'adulte de savoir
que l'on ne touche pas à un enfant
peut-on tenir sur les zones mans avec un
mineur de 15 ans bien entendu il faut
également protéger les mineurs de moins
de 15 ans d'une relation non consentie
et l'amendement de notre rapporteur vise
à aider le juge à conclure qu'un manque
de maturité peut équivaloir à la
contrainte et à la surprise il permet
donc de répondre à cette nécessité de
protection accrue des plus jeunes sans
pour autant juger de la pertinence d'une
relation entre deux jeunes dont l'un
serait majeure la différence das est
effectivement on peut considérer qu'il
n'ya pas une histoire d'amour entre un
jeune de terminale es un jeune qui entre
tout juste au collège entre seconde et
terminale c'est parfois plus discutable
voilà pourquoi notre collègue annie
guillon a choisi et propose cet âge de
13 ans mais nous disent les avocates que
nous avons auditionné les auteurs disent
et diront toujours qu'ils ne connaissent
pas l'âge de leurs victimes
ah bon pourtant 87% des auteurs sont
dans le cercle rapproché de l'enfant
parents beaux-parents oncle entraîneur
sportif je vous invite à regarder l
avalanche de témoignages sur twitter
auquel on a déjà fait référence avec le
hashtag mitu inceste
quasiment tous les agresseurs
connaissent leur victime et donc
évidemment son âge regardons ce fléau
tel qu'il est un agresseur choisi sa
victime l'entraînent dans sa nasse et
l'as bayonne à vie par le mal qu'il lui
a fait et il connaît son âge il ne peut
prétendre le contraire
la seule chose qui prétend d'ailleurs en
général c'est que l'enfant était
consentant il n'aura pu le faire
non l'enfant n'est jamais qu'on s'entend
quand bien même dit-il oui et que l'on
ne vienne pas nous parler d'enfants
séducteur oui l'enfant veut plaire oui
l'enfant à séduire mais ce qu'il demande
c'est de l'amour de l'infection pas une
relation sexuelle pas un viol c'est à
l'adulte de savoir maîtriser ses
pulsions car lui c'est et si cette loi
est adoptée
il saura que ses 20 ans de prison la
question de l' imprescriptibilité a
également été posée une victime de viol
c'est terrible ce sens elle même
coupable quand elle ne souffre pas
d'amnésie traumatique
alors c'est sûr que l'âge de 48 ans à
savoir 30 ans après la majorité
ça peut être insuffisant le problème
n'est pas celui de la preuve
contrairement à ce qu'on nous dit
souvent en effet en cas d'inceste ou de
viols dans le cercle de confiance de
l'enfant souvent l'auteur lui même
reconnaît les faits pour peu que la
victime parle mais peut-être
reconnaît-il d'autant mieux les faits
qu'ils sont prescrits ça effectivement
il faudrait l'étudier
en tout état de cause nous avons en
france ce qui n'est pas le cas dans tous
les pays une hiérarchie de la
prescription rendre le viol sur mineure
imprescriptible pourquoi pas mais chaque
victimes de crimes comme des meurtres
sera aussi en mesure de demander
l'imprescriptibilité et c'est toute la
notion de hiérarchie des crimes et de
droit à l'oubli qui devra être revisitée
pourquoi pas mais il me semble qu'un tel
débat n'est pas suffisamment avancée
aujourd'hui pour prendre une telle
décision
l'inceste enfin un inceste et un inceste
quel que soit l'âge auquel il se produit
là encore un travail approfondi est
nécessaire mais je sais monsieur le
ministre taquet que vous le mener
l'aggravation de la tam sexuelle en cas
de relations incestueuses est une
première étape nous n'avons pas fini
notre travail donc de protection des
mineurs mais dans un premier temps
créons un interdit créons ce seuil c'est
un petit pas peut-être mais c'est un
pass certains faisant le et messieurs
les ministres
inscrivez ce texte à l'assemblée
nationale
il n'est plus temps de réfléchir ça fait
deux ans qu'on en parle
je pense que aujourd'hui on a déjà bien
répondu à toutes les questions qui se
posent merci donc encore un aiguillon
d'avoir cette proposition de loi est
évidemment le groupe union centriste la
votera merci chers collègues dans la
suite de la discussion
la parole est à madame marie pierre de
la gontrie pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste républicains pour six minutes
bonjour monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres
madame la vice présidente de la
commission des lois
madame la rapporteure mes chers
collègues merci merci aux signataires de
cette proposition de loi dont d'ailleurs
l'appartenance et trans partisane
merci aux associations de leur
mobilisation
merci au groupe union centriste d'avoir
choisi d'inscrire ce texte dans un temps
limité qui va nous amener d'ailleurs et
je m'applique à moi même à une grande
sobriété dans nos propos je ne sais si
je peut adjoindre ses remerciements à
cette liste de remerciements le
gouvernement dont j'ai entendu à la fois
l'ouverture d'esprit à l'égard de ce
texte mais le souhait de continuer de
réfléchir ce qui n'est jamais très bon
signe
en manière de travail en matière de
travail parlementaire mais nous l'avons
déjà vu et mes collègues parlementaires
députés du groupe socialiste ont déjà
annoncé que si ce texte voté aujourd'hui
et est conforme à nos attentes
et si le gouvernement n'était pas très
allants il inscrirait dans leur propre
temps parlementaire à l'assemblée pour
que ce texte puisse prospérer
alors l'essentiel de ce texte est sans
doute de fixer enfin un seuil d'âge
jeudi enfin parce que permettez moi
d'être un petit peu taquine
nous avons proposé au groupe socialiste
un seuil d'âge il y a deux ans cela a
été refusé
c'était l'âge de 13 ans bien les choses
ont évolué et c'est une bonne chose
le seuil d'âge est une question délicate
au sein de notre propre groupe les avis
divergent
la question n'est pas anodine mais
l'importance de ce seuil d'âge me
semble-t-il est un tournant c'est pour
cela qu'il faut dire merci au delà
évidemment ce seuil d'âge permet quoi
d'évacuer la question du consentement de
ne plus essayer de tergiverser et de
savoirs et d'interroger la victime pour
savoir si oui ou non elle a dit non elle
a dit oui
elle savait on savait qu'elle avait quel
âge etc etc bref l'âge du consentement
est une donnée désormais qui est acté et
donc cette notion de consentement et
quartier nous proposons pour notre part
trois pistes d'amélioration certaines
j'en suis heureuse retenu par la
commission des lois
mais ce n'est pas suffisant en direction
des victimes en direction des auteurs en
direction des témoins en direction des
victimes
nous avons présenté un amendement que
nous proposerons un nouveau tout à
l'heure sur lequel nous serons une
demande de scrutin public qui visera à
fixer à 18 ans l'âge d'une non
consentement
concernant le crime d'inceste il n'est
pas acceptable d'avancé dans ce texte
sur l'âge de 13 ans certains
souhaiteraient 15 et de ne pas avancer
sur la question de l'inceste le sénat
ratera une occasion donc nous devons
avancer sur ce point le deuxième point
c'est en direction des auteurs on a
beaucoup parlé on reparlera peut-être si
nous en avons le temps de la question de
la prescription et l'imprescriptibilité
il y à un moyen assez
utile en tout cas qui a d'ailleurs déjà
été votée par le sénat en 2018 et puis
qui par le miracle de la commission
mixte paritaire a disparu du texte
c'est la question de l'interruption de
la prescription en cas de multiplicité
de victimes c'est très important la
multiplicité de victimes parce que c'est
souvent parce qu'il est victime
multiples que du coup l'agresseur est
confondu et que les victimes sont crus
et nous avons nous l'avons vu dans la
sphère flavie flament et dans d'autres
que les victimes connaissent un sort qui
leur semble ce n'est pas faux
inéquitable en raison de la prescription
et donc demandé précisé prévoir
l'interruption de la prescription en
temps en temps que en cas de victimes
multiples permet en cas d'auteur en
série soyons clairs et c'est très
souvent le cas de pouvoir poursuivre
enfin en direction des témoins
potentiels
il existe aujourd'hui dans notre droit
le délit de non dénonciation de
violences sur enfants maltraitance
atteintes sexuelles etc
le problème c'est que ce délit est un
délit et que sa prescription est
particulière nous proposons que il soit
cette prescription soit prolongée d'une
part à compter de la majorité de la
victime et qu'elle soit prolongée de dix
ans j'ai bien noté que la rapporteur a
proposées allant encore plus loin que
cela soit prolongé de dix ans en cas de
délit non dénoncés de 20 en cas de crime
c'est une très bonne chose et je pense
que nous vous rejoindront sur ce point
il faut faire peser sur les potentiels
témoins le poids de la responsabilité y
compris pénale
tout cela ne permettra pas
nécessairement d'éradiquer le phénomène
mais c'est en convergence sur cette
interdiction que nous ferons peut-être
que les enfants seront mieux protégés
alors vous l'avez compris le groupe
socialiste est favorable à ce texte
il le trouve incomplet il le trouve pas
rapport imprécis et nous avons entre
nous des discussions sur la question de
l'âge mais dans ce domaine nous l'avons
vu c'est le parlement qui avance
c'est le parlement qui parfois tort un
peu le bras
du gouvernement nous l'avons vu
d'ailleurs au moment des violences sur
les femmes avec la proposition de loi
qui émanait du député et l'air aurélien
pradié qui finalement a trouvé
aboutissement ici grâce au sénat donc
continuons dans cette voie
transpartisane jeu j'adjure le sénat de
voter les améliorations que nous
proposons est de ne pas rater passer à
côté du train de l'histoire qui
permettra enfin de sanctionner de
manière efficace les auteurs de crimes
sexuels sur les enfants mineurs
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
la discussion la parole est à monsieur
stéphane ravier non inscrits pour le
groupe non inscrits pour 3 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la sphère
duhamel et écoeurante révoltante
alors a le mérite de mettre en lumière
la responsabilité de tous ces soixante
huitard cantons qui ont imposé
l'interdiction d'interdire y compris les
rapports sexuels entre majeurs et
mineurs une révolution qui ne s'est pas
contenté de la pensée mais qui est passé
aux actes et qui nous conduit
aujourd'hui finalement à devoir
légiférer pour tenter d'empêcher ou de
sanctionner l'ignominie quant au silence
jusqu'au déni de tout ce qu'ils savent
qu'ils cautionnent elle reste tout
autant condamnable
il est urgent d'encourager la libération
de la parole pour libérer la souffrance
des victimes être ferme avec les
coupables en les punissant sévèrement et
demander des comptes aux complices
passifs des enfants les familles ne
peuvent appréhender l'avenir que dans la
confiance l'équilibré la sérénité il
faut que la justice de notre pays assure
donc une application des peines claire
et ferme et permettent une transparence
totale sur ses actes abjects tout en
cherchant comme objectif ultime protéger
ces mineurs des prédateurs sexuels fixé
la barre de l'interdiction absolue de
tout acte sexuel entre un majeur et un
mineur de 13 ans ne doit pas priver les
mineurs de moins de 15 ans de la
protection qui leur garantit encore
aujourd'hui si je soutiens ces textes
nous ne devons pas abandonner
l'impérieuse nécessité de protéger les
mineurs âgés de 13 à 15 ans il ne
saurait y avoir une quelconque forme de
dépénalisation pour des actes sexuels
commis sur des enfants issus de cette
tranche d'âge
il ya aussi une autre tolérance
sournoise envers ces agissements qu'il
nous faut des films ci définitivement
bannir ces individus qui n'ont aucune
victime directe avéré mekhissi lui des
tribunes dans la presse pour tenter de
décriminaliser les rapports sexuels avec
des mineures ou tient des propos qui
banalisent la pédophilie ces apprentis
sorciers doivent prendre des comptes
le discours nauséabond qu'il véhicule
doit être sévèrement condamnés on
interdit
répandre des messages appelant à la
haine et à la violence sous toutes ses
formes
il faut également être implacable avec
ceux qui banalisent en public des
comportements graves et des crimes
sexuels pédophiles
on ne saurait admettre plus longtemps
que l'on puisse se vanter sur les
plateaux télé de prendre du plaisir
quand les enfants jouent avec votre
braguette
ces sinistres individus ne devraient
plus être invité sur des plateaux mais
être envoyé derrière les barreaux
les collectivités territoriales éduqués
et l'éducation nationale doivent
encourager des associations dont les
messages vont dans le sens de la
prévention
il est également urgent d'établir dans
notre droit une imprescriptibilité pour
les crimes sexuels commis sur des
mineurs quel que soit leur âge c'est
imprescriptibilité justifié par
l'extrême difficulté à parler et donc à
aborder publiquement de tels actes y
compris lorsque la victime a atteint
l'âge adulte un enfant abusé un enfant
violée
c'est un crime contre l'innocence c'est
une blessure jamais cicatrisées c'est
toute une vie jalonnée de souffrance
alors mes chers collègues et sachons
protéger totalement avec une loi claire
et une justice impitoyable ce que nous
avons de plus précieux
nos enfants les adultes de demain vous
en seront reconnaissants
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
discussions générales la parole est à
madame vanina paoli gaza pour le groupe
indépendant république et territoires
pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur ministre madame la
rapporteure madame la vice présidente
michèle collègues parce qu'elle touche à
l'intimé et parce qu'elles ont de graves
conséquences psychologiques
les infractions sexuelles quand
durablement au pouvoir éternellement la
vie des victimes lorsque ces dernières
sont des enfants personnes vulnérables
les effets n'en sont que plus
dévastateur et c'est notre société tout
entière qui sont trop fragilisés il est
donc impératif de mieux protéger les
mineurs contre les atteintes
je crois que nous partageons tous
l'objectif porté par la proposition de
notre collègue
les évolutions récentes sont positives
en 2018 la loi contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes a apporté à notre
droit malgré cela et au delà même des
difficultés probatoire propres à ce type
d'infraction la protection des enfants
demeure fragile et insuffisante la
répression des agressions sexuelles dont
le viol fait partie il centré sur la
notion d' absence de consentement de la
victime ce fondement paradoxal convient
mal vous m'en sors et grey à deux jeunes
individus dont le discernement est
nécessairement au cours de construction
la répression des atteintes sexuelles
sur mineur de 15 ans quant à elle a pour
objet de poser un interdit social en
défendant au majeur toute relation
sexuelle avec ses moins de 15 ans mais
il s'agit d'un simple délit dont les
peines ne sont pas assez lourde
le dispositif proposé par notre collègue
annie billon vise à criminaliser toute
relation sexuelle impliquant pénétration
même sans violence entre un mineur de 13
ans et un majeur
cette nouvelle infraction se situe donc
sous l'angle de la qualification pénale
aux frontières du viol et de l'atteinte
sexuelle sur mineur c'est une avancée
mais je pense qu'il est important de
renforcer
significativement l'interdisent sociale
pour ce qui est de ce type de relation
nous devons protéger nos enfants pour
eux mêmes d'abord car ces atteintes ont
des effets destructeurs qui s'inscrivent
dans la durée et elle infecte
insidieusement tout le corps social
nous devons aussi protéger nos enfants
pour les adultes qu'ils seront pour les
familles qui le fonde rond et pour la
société que nous voulons demain beaucoup
d'agresseurs sont eux mêmes ont eux
mêmes étaient des victimes d'abus ce
cycle doit être brisé à ce titre notre
groupe les indépendants soutient le
renforcement des sanctions en toutes
circonstances les adultes doivent
protéger les enfants ce qui leur portent
atteinte à être lourdement sanctionnés
et ceux qui ont connaissance de ces abus
doivent alerter les autorités sous peine
de sanctions alourdies
je veux ici insisté sur l'importance de
ces signalements lorsqu'il s'agit
d'enfants
beaucoup ne diront pas les abus qu'ils
subissent parce que même s'ils
ressentent souvent ils peuvent ne pas
les concevoir comme des abus quand ils
proviennent de deux personnes ayant
autorité sur parce qu'ils ne sont
souvent pas à même tout simplement de
nous mais et parce qu'une sentent ils se
sentent trop souvent pardon coupable de
ce qui leur arrive mais aussi parce
qu'ils ne savent pas toujours s'ils
doivent ou s'ils peuvent en parler
il est de notre devoir je pense de
désamorcer cette bombe à retardement et
à déflagration dans ces affaires
l'omerta c'est aussi le camp du mal elle
doit cesser
c'est pourquoi je vous proposerait deux
amendements le premier fixant un délai
de prescription du délit de
non-dénonciation à 20 ans après la
majorité de la victime et le second en
forçant au conséquemment les peines
encourues en aggravant les sanctions des
auteurs d'infractions sexuelles sur
mineurs et en brisant la loi du silence
je suis convaincu que nous contribuerons
à mieux protéger nos enfants c'est notre
responsabilité mes chers collègues
monsieur le garde des sceaux que deux
tracés ici et maintenant une ligne
claire entre la barbarie et la
civilisation
nous le devons à la fois au nom des
grands principes mais aussi des grands
sentiments
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame esther benbassa pour le groupe
écologiste solidaire solidarité et
territoires pour ce 4e minute
bonjour monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres
madame annick billon auteurs de ce ppr
madame la rapporteur charles collègues
165000 est le nombre estimé de mineurs
j'inclus le féminin aussi mais qui ne se
voit pas n'est ce pas l'oral qui subit
chaque année en france des violences
sexuelles ce sens 130000 filles et 35000
garçon que le droit n'aura pas su
protéger les difficultés en la matière
sont de plusieurs ordres
tout d'abord ces violences demain trop
peu dénoncé si l'on s'en tient aux
chiffres officiels du ministère de
l'intérieur ont le sens en 2019 à peine
plus de sept mille plaintes peu
d'agressions font l'objet de plaintes
parce que nombre d'entre elles se
produisent malheureusement dans le cadre
de la famille mais nous ne pouvons
ignorer qu'il existe des difficultés
d'ordre juridique car si le dépôt de ces
plaintes est en nette augmentation
depuis quelques années le droit en ce
domaine complexe en pêche trop souvent
que celles ci aboutissent à une
condamnation
le texte de la loi renforçant la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes adoptée en août 2018 aillent
porteur de deux améliorations
significatives
il a permis l'allongement des délais de
prescription pour les crimes sexuels
commis sur mineurs et à préciser la
définition du viol dans le cas d'une
victime de moins de 15 ans mais c'est
toi reste est inachevée n'ayant pas
créer un seuil d'âge précis en dessous
duquel toute personne adulte qui a eu un
rapport sexuel avec une personne mineure
tomberait sous le coup d'une
condamnation
la proposition de loi dont nous
débattons cosigné par plus de cent
sénatrices et sénateurs de tous bords
politiques vise donc à mettre un terme à
cette situation juridique ou de tels
actes ne sont pas systématiquement
considéré comme un viol
elle peut ainsi dans la loi une limite
claire prévoyant l'interdiction absolue
de tout accès qu suel entre une personne
majeure et une ou un mineur de moins de
13 ans en outre l'ajout suite aux
travaux de la commission des lois de
l'article 1er bis qui prévoit des
protections supplémentaires pour la
tranche d'âge de 13 à 15 ans mérite
d'être salué
toutefois certains d'entre nous aurait
préféré que le seuil retenu par cette
ppl soit celui de 15 ans à l'aune du
hashtag mythe ou 1,16 à l'aune également
de la récente étude menée par
l'association face à l'unfp 16 estimant
à près de 6,7 millions de françaises et
français comme victime d'inceste la
politique des petits pas en matière de
crimes sexuels sur mineurs n'est plus
envisageable
nous souhaitons par ailleurs d'autres
améliorations tout particulièrement la
reconnaissance des luco génitaux comme
crimes sexuels et le groupe écologiste a
fait un amendement dans ce sens de même
à l'avenir il serait tôt portant de
bénéficier de données officielles plus
précise et plus régulières
quant aux violences sexuelles commis sur
personne mineure pour autant cette
proposition de loi est nécessaire et
nous en soyons l'initiative c'est la
raison pour laquelle le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire votera pour son
adoption
monsieur le ministre je voulais ajouter
que nous avons fait un excellent travail
au sénat sur cette ppl de madame billaut
mais chaque fois que les que l'exécutif
de passer par dessus la tête des
parlementaires il le fait cela a été le
cas avec le texte de madame chiappe en
2018 qui venait après le texte du sénat
maintenant allez vous faire la même
chose en vous appelant à une nouvelle
consultation sur la question en dehors
du parlement probablement pour préparer
encore un nouveau texte
merci chers soleil dans la suite de la
discussion la parole est à madame jacky
d'euromédis pour le groupe l'est
républicain pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
madame le rapporteur mes chers collègues
nous nous réunissons aujourd'hui à
nouveau avec la ferme intention de
renforcer la protection de nos enfants
comme nous l'avions fait au mois de juin
dernier lors de l'examen de la loi
visant à protéger les victimes de
violences conjugales
mais aujourd'hui l'objectif est d'autant
plus complexe qu il est précis puisqu'il
s'agit d'améliorer la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles commises sur deux
très jeunes mineurs
l'ambition première de l'auteur de cette
proposition de loi
cher indique billon est telle que nous
la comprenons de couvrir les faits de
viols perpétrés sur des mineurs de moins
de 13 ans le groupe des républicains du
sénat ne peut que souscrire à l'analyse
selon laquelle le viol sur mineure
notamment sur deux très jeunes victimes
se révèle encore particulièrement
difficile à caractériser à poursuivre et
à condamner mais si la définition de
viol complexe à appréhender et trop
restrictive selon certains sera
certainement au coeur de nos débats cet
après midi il nous semble cependant que
la première des questions qui s'imposent
aujourd'hui à nous est de savoir si la
loi aujourd'hui en vigueur fixe un
interdit sociétal suffisamment claire
intelligible et non équivoque pour un
certain nombre de professionnels qu'ils
exercent dans le milieu de la santé de
l'éducation ou encore de la justice nos
dispositions en matière pénale suffisent
déjà à réprimer l'ensemble des violences
sexuelles commises sur deux jeunes
mineurs pourtant si l'on en croit la
forte émotion suscitée dans le débat
public ces derniers jours par la
parution du livre la familia grande et
de kamil kouchner la réponse à cette
question semble moins évidente
or comme le remarquait portalis dans le
discours préliminaire sur le projet de
code civil il est temps il est des temps
où l'on est condamné parce qu'on manque
de livres
il en est d'autres où il est difficile
de s'instruire parce qu'on en a trop
qu'il s'agisse de détermination d'un
seuil d'âge 13 ans ou 15 ans ou de
l'institution d'une infraction autonome
plutôt que d'une présomption les avis
diffèrent souvent d'un citoyen à l'autre
et de la même façon d'un législateur à
un autre notre groupe ne fait pas
exception en la matière cependant la
position élaboré par la commission des
lois nous semble à la fois prudente et
pertinente en particulier l'introduction
dans le texte de la notion de maturité
sexuelle est intéressante en ce qu'elle
permettrait aux magistrats pénétrées de
l'esprit général des lois à en diriger
l'application pour citer un nouveau
portalis selon qui les lois positives ne
saurait jamais entièrement remplacé l'
usage de la raison naturelle dans les
affaires de la vie aussi nous saluons la
proposition du rapporteur d'accroître la
protection des mineurs âgés de 13 à 15
ans en précisant que la contrainte ou la
surprise peut résulter de ce que la
victime mineure et est âgée de moins de
15 ans il ne disposait pas de la
maturité sexuelle suffisante pour
conclure je tiens à remercier notre
rapporteur chère marie mercier pour la
qualité et l'humanité de son travail
à propos d'un sujet aussi sensible que
délicat pour l'ensemble des raisons
évoquées je ne doute pas que les membres
du groupe lr voteront cette proposition
de loi tel qu amendé par la commission
des lois
je vous en remercie merci chers
collègues dans la suite et la fin de
cette discussion générale la parole est
à madame alexandra porc cuit au fond
frontale pour l'europe les républicains
pour cinq minutes hommes
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
madame la rapporteure chers collègues
protéger nos enfants
trois mots qui paraissent évidents trois
mots qui traduisent finalement le
souhait de tous parents cette protection
parce qu indispensable d'être à nouveau
renforcé face au nombre effrayant de
violences sexuelles commises sur des
mineurs la sphère médiatique mettant en
cause le politiste olivier duhamel pour
des abus sexuels commis sur son beau
fils à peine âgée de 13 ans au moment
des faits a bien sûr raviver le débat la
douleur et la colère pourquoi at il
fallu attendre autant de temps pour que
la parole se libère
aujourd'hui les français ne peuvent plus
accepter cette omerta cela leur est
insupportable à l'image du à chan meetoo
inceste qui déferle sur les réseaux
sociaux alors hasard du calendrier le
sénat est aujourd'hui réunies pour
débattre de ce sujet nous savons que les
violences sexuelles à l'encontre des
enfants sont souvent perpétrés au sein
de la famille aussi je pense que nous
serons tous d'accord dans cet hémicycle
pour affirmer que toute violence à
caractère sexuel à l'encontre de mineurs
dont l'un 700 sujets tabous quand il est
abject doivent être combattus et punis à
la hauteur de leurs atrocités briser le
silence et le premier impératif briser
le silence douloureux des victimes qui
n'osent pas parler briser le silence et
éhontée de ce qui assurément savez
l'amendement de la rapporteure qui vise
à étendre le délai de prescription pour
inciter au signalement est un pas
nécessaire dans le combat que nous
menons ma fille va avoir 13 ans cette
année à 13 en est encore un enfant mes
chers collègues la proposition de loi
que nous nous apprêtons à examiner ne
fait que le rappeler visant ainsi à
l'amélioration de la protection que nous
leur devons lorsque des prédateurs
sexuels abusent de nos enfants c'est la
société tout entière qui en ressort
affaibli anéanti tous les élus locaux
peuvent témoigner d'affaires dans leur
territoire le département des
alpes-maritimes n'y échappe pas j'ai
changé encore ce matin sur le sujet avec
un magistrat de grasse en charge des
violences sexuelles
le constat est trans partisan et ne
laisse la place à aucun doute la
protection des mineurs présentent encore
des failles que le législateur doit
combler le sénat
sous l'impulsion de philippe bas dressé
dans son rapport de 2018 déjà confié à
marie mercier un état des lieux alarmant
les préconisations de ce rapport avait
été traduite dans la proposition de loi
d'orientation et de programmation pour
une meilleure protection des mineurs
victimes d'infractions sexuelles
adopté par le sénat en mars 2018 plus
que les vaines paroles c'est une
nouvelle manifestation du volontarisme
et de la détermination de notre groupe à
agir sur ces questions pour les victimes
bien que l'assemblée nationale n'est
toujours pas donné suite allant ainsi à
l'encontre de la demande récurrente de
notre société sur ce sujet le sénat
n'abandonne pas la délégation aux droits
des femmes du sénat dont je suis membre
a produit sous la présidence d'annie
guillon de nombreux travaux tous visait
à alerter sur la nécessité de faciliter
la répression des viols commis à
l'encontre de mineurs est préconisée en
conséquence la création d'une infraction
autonome de crimes de pénétration
sexuelle sur mineure de 13 ans les
améliorations issus d amendement de la
rapporteure permettent d'assurer que
cette proposition de loi et de façon
certaine une pierre fondamentale dans
l'édifice protecteur que nous sommes en
train de bâtir pour nos enfants
si les insuffisances de la loi schiappa
du 3 août 2010 huit sont satisfaites
puisque la définition du crime sexuel
sur mineur est élargi aux actes de
pénétrations sexuelles commis par la
victime sur l'auteur d'autres garanties
sont à souligner dans son avis du 21
mars 2018 le conseil d'état avait jugé
que les défauts de rédaction du
dispositif alors proposée par le
gouvernement était dangereux la teneur
du débat et la grandeur des attentes et
des victimes et proches des victimes
n'avaient pas suffi à empêcher l'abandon
pur et simple de cette mesure alors sans
créer de prévention de non consentement
mais sans non plus renoncer les
amendements déposés adopté en commission
des lois répondre aux inquiétudes
exprimées ainsi cette proposition doit
permet le respect de nos obligations
constitutionnelles mais accroît et
consolide de concert la protection des
enfants en simplifiant le travail des
magistrats fier de l'avancé permises par
ces travaux le sénat doit aujourd'hui et
continuer son combat
ces nouveaux instruments marque une
avancée certaine dans l'alu
contre les violences sexuelles à
l'encontre des enfants mais d'autres
questions restent en suspens
l'allongement du délai de la peine
encourue notamment quand on sait que
l'auteur à l'aide de bécanes isme de
remise de peine par exemple ne fait que
souvent la moitié de la peine prononcée
peine jugée trop faible par les victimes
et leurs familles mes chers collègues
ces sujets méritent que notre
institution le prenne à bras le corps
avec force et vigueur
ne laissons plus ces crimes perdurer ne
laissons plus nos enfants en danger
alors je vous écoute
messieurs les mini ministre finalement
nous menons le même combat avec la même
volonté la même intensité
et bien ce combat il se gagne ici et
maintenant je vous remercie
merci chers collègues je vais passer la
parole à madame là le rapporteur je me
suis dis merci beaucoup monsieur le
président nous sommes en train d'évoquer
des violences faites aux enfants ou si
je voudrais profiter de votre présence
ces deux ministres pour vous parler des
violences le liés à l'exposition aux
films pornographiques aux images
pornographiques souvent dès le collège
vous étiez là le 38 quand nous avions
voté cet amendement bien sûr c'était un
procédé très technique mais notre
commission est très attentive au devenir
de cet amendement qui permettait de
protéger les mineurs en faisant en sorte
qu'ils n'acceptent pas très facilement
aux sites pornographiques gratuit
réservé aux majeurs
aussi monsieur ministre j'aimerais que
prochainement vous puissiez nous faire
un point sur ce sujet merci monsieur le
ministre garde des sceaux monsieur le
président monsieur le président la
commission des lois madame la
rapporteure mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs une réponse très très très
très rapide pour rassurer d'abord votre
assemblée le but
du gouvernement ce n'est pas un but
dilatoire qui seraient cachés on prend
cette proposition de loi comme une
proposition de loi extrêmement
intéressante
bien sûr je vous essayez de vous
rassurer j'ai entendu quelques
circonspection s'exprimer en réalité ce
que nous disons c'est que bien sûr nous
devons travailler ensemble que nous
n'avons pas d'exclusive quant aux
vecteurs qui sera utilisée qu il est
nécessaire de faire quelque chose et
nous sommes c'est que le comprendre dans
un consensus sur l'idée générale
cependant il ya un certain nombre de
points qui méritent tout de même d'être
selon nous encore un peu travaillé et
c'est la raison pour laquelle avec
adrien taquet je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que nous souhaitions encore
consulter un peu pas pour gagner du
temps il est indispensable conde répond
à cette attente que nous en tant que
nous entendons tous mais regardez je
voudrais préciser mon propos je voudrais
préciser le propos quel est le seuil que
nous devons choisir 13 14 15
il faut il parle j'ai pas tout à fait
terminée il faut réfléchir sur ces
questions parce que ce débat évidemment
nous engage et je les dis je le dis nous
n'avons pas le droit à l'erreur première
question le seuil 12e mais est ce que je
peux vous répondre tranquillement
rapidement deuxième question comment
qualifier ce nouveau crime viol paziols
vraie question véritable attente des
associations
comment articuler au mieux les
différents dispositifs satisfaire le
principe de nécessité des peines de
proportionnalité des peines le nôtre
vous a dit tout à l'heure si vous voulez
me ventre et je crois que il y avait
encore un certain nombre de questions
qui se pose est que vous alliez
évidemment ajouté le texte mais qu' il y
avait un certain nombre d'interrogations
qui n'avait pas encore obtenu de réponse
la prescription pour satisfaire au mieux
ces questions qui sont des questions
absolument essentiel
autre question de la prescription
glissante extrêmement intéressant comme
il est mais il faut encore y travailler
un peu bon voilà autant de questions que
nous allons évoquer à l'occasion de ces
débats nous souhaitons participer
pleinement à ces débats ce n'est pas les
députés contre les sénateurs les
sénateurs contre le gouvernement je ne
sais rien on est tous ensemble et unis
dans une véritable concertation mais je
le redis il ya un certain nombre de
divergences et il ya un certain nombre
de choses qui ne sont pas encore tranché
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai dit
tout à l'heure que nous souhaitions
recevoir un certain nombre d
intervenants qui sont au fait de ces
situations absolument dramatique et vous
aurez et nous aurons évidemment
collectivement à apporter une réponse
dont je tiens ici à préciser qu'elle
doit être rapide mais pas dans la
précipitation
voilà on va réfléchir
merci
merci monsieur le ministre mes services
et en gros socialiste a évoqué ces
questions de prescription et il a dit
avec le talent qui est le sien à quel
point ces questions sont difficiles à
trancher bon prenons encore un peu de
réflexion s'il vous plaît merci monsieur
le ministre la discussion générale et
klose mes chers collègues nous passons à
discussion du texte de la commission
à l'article 1er j'ai des demandes de
prise de parole tout d'abord madame
valérie boyer merci monsieur le
président permettez moi mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre vous dire
que au parlement que ce soit au sénat ou
à l'assemblée nationale les
parlementaires travaillent ils prennent
le temps ils ne sont pas dans la
précipitation et ça fait un moment
qu'ils ont réagi sur ces questions alors
nous devons à nos enfants une vie sans
violence et sans peur tout au long de
nos débats aujourd'hui ayant à l'esprit
ces mots de nelson mandela
c'est en pensant à ces mots que je veux
féliciter la présidente annick billon
pour son travail son engagement son
ouverture d'esprit et également salué
notre rapporteur marie mercier
sans oublier tous les parlementaires qui
travaille depuis de nombreuses années
sur cette question sur les violences
sexuelles sans précipitation aussi même
si nous aurons des débats sur les
aspects juridiques car c'est notre
responsabilité de parlementaires nous
avons aussi ici un seul et même objectif
protéger les plus vulnérables les
différences amendement que je défendrai
sont le fruit de plusieurs années de
travaux et d'auditions d'experts et de
juristes
je pense au conseil et à l'égalité au
juge pour enfants edouard durant à
ernestine ronai muriel salmona au centre
hubertine auclert amel trn attali
tommasini michel créoff ou encore
françoise laborde
ce sont ces auditions qui m'ont conduite
a considéré que la loi de 2018 dit
schiappa étaient soit rendez vous
manqués soit des petits pas et qu'il
faut vraiment aller plus loin ce sont
des auditions qui me conduise à dire que
nous devons aller plus loin sur le seuil
d'âge ça a été largement évoquée et je
voudrais vous citer ici les mots du chef
de l'état qui disait je veux ici vous
donnez une conviction personnelle
nous devrions nous aligner sur l'âge de
la majorité sexuelle fixés dans notre
droit à 15 ans par souci de cohérence et
de protection des mineurs alors avançons
instituer un seuil d'âge pour les
infractions de violences sexuelles
commises par des adultes sur des mineurs
est une solution retenue par de nombreux
états qui veille également au respect
des droits de la défense alors mes chers
collègues
faisons ensemble reculé cette réalité
effroyable un enfant est violée toutes
les heures en france et je terminerai
par ses propos du juge durant qui dit
que le passage à l'acte de l'adulte est
une perversion du besoin affectif de
l'enfant
en aucun cas l'enfant ne peut être
consentant pour une relation sexuelle
à nous d'y mettre un terme merci chers
collègues
la parole est à vous ce max brisson si
le sou président et cher collègue au
1110 en 2018 que fut de ceux qui
ressortir meurtri de nos débats ma liste
manifestement les travaux de la
délégation aux droits des femmes
n'avaient pas suffisamment mature et
pour que sa position fille suivis par le
gouvernement et le sénat je me réjouis
donc ce matin que la proposition de loi
taglio concrétise nos débats et nos
travaux et que nous parvenions avec cet
article premier à instaurer un seuil
d'âge à 13 ans pour interdire tout acte
de pénétration sexuelle
je me réjouis aussi de la proche de la
commission des lois de son président et
d'un rapporteur marie mercier qui ont
judicieusement enrichit la proposition
de loi d'un million sept hâtive premier
donc une avancée certes je suis de ceux
qui auraient préféré que le seuil fixé à
15 ans mais je comprends et me rallie
aux arguments de l'auteur d'approbation
de loi parce qu'elle évoque les
relations sexuelles consenties entre
adolescents est très jeune majeur je
comprends moins en revanche les propos
quasiment méprisant de la boue ministre
délégué à la citoyenneté qui sont un
plateau de télévision ce week-end
s'apitoyer sur le sort réservé aux 13 15
ans pas cette proposition de loi
dois je faire remarquer à l'ancien
secrétaire d'état à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes que le texte a été
sur le sujet judicieusement enrichi par
marie mercier et que marlène schiappa en
2018 avancé les mêmes arguments que ceux
qui nous ont été servis tout à l'heure
par le garde des sceaux
mais laissons là c'est bien
et politiques et saluons le travail
concerté de la commission des lois et de
la délégation aux droits des femmes et
la constance et la combativité de sa
présidente annie billon qui peut être
satisfaite du cheminement des esprits
depuis 2018
monsieur le garde des sceaux emparez
vous de ce texte
améliorer le mais nous vous affirmez pas
une nouvelle fois dans le dédale des
comités théodule fait confiance au
parlement
améliorer le texte amendé le fait vivre
la navette et la démocratie
parlementaire
merci chers collègues trois amendements
discussion commune
nous commençons par le 3 juillet
monsieur le président vanessa springer
avait 15 ans le jeune kouchner 14 ans
sarah abitbol 15 ans elisabeth demongeot
avait 14 ans flavie flament avait à
peine 13 ans et combien d'autres
victimes encore la société dans son
ensemble doit s'interroger sur ce
qu'elle tolère ou ce qu'elle ne veut pas
voir aussi je crois que nous devons
envoyer un message simple il met fort il
ya une présomption de contrainte en cas
de relations sexuelles entre mineurs de
moins de 15 ans et un majeur lorsque ce
dernier connaissait on ne pouvait
ignorer l'âge de la victime
et j'insiste sur le mot contrainte et
non consentement ou seul l'auteur est
responsable de ses actes philippe bas
l'a parfaitement expliqué en commission
le consentement n'est pas un bon
instrument et ce qui doit être utilisé
en droit pénal c'est la contrainte se
reposer s'appuyer sur le consentement
c'est moins protéger la victime se
reposer s'appuyer sur la contrainte
c'est faire reposer la charge de la
preuve sur l'agresseur avec le
dispositif que je propose et je sais que
vous n'avez pas retenu mais je tenais
quand elle défendre nous pourrons
sanctuariser la protection des mineurs
de moins de 15 ans ce seuil est connue
de tous
il correspond à ce que nous résumons pas
l'âge de la majorité sexuelle même si
cette notion mérite d'être mieux défini
en aucun cas à l'enfant de moins de 15
ans ne peut être consentant une relation
sexuelle
nous devons y mettre un terme
l'adolescent de 13 14 ou 15 ans est en
pleine puberté il cherche une identité
il reste influençable et va croire les
mots de l'adulte il n'a pas la maturité
pour être vraiment qu'on s'entend comme
l'expliquent justement walesa skin gorin
enfin cet amendement respecte deux
principes fondamentaux celui de la
présomption d'innocence
en effet l'infraction ne sera pas
systématique dès lors qu'il faudra
prouver l'acte la nature de l'acte et
démontrer que l'auteur connaissait ou
nos poubelles ignorer la victime
les juges pourront toujours en rendre
compte des circonstances apprécier la
réalité puisqu'il ya notion de
connaissance de l'âge de la victime
l'infraction n'est jamais automatique
voici le sens de ces deux amendements
que je défends en même temps d'accord
donc le 3 et le cateau ont été défendus
le cas précis identique aux 14 le 14 mai
mme cohen qui est le fond oui merci
monsieur le président il était en partie
défendu les le fruit d'une réflexion
qu'ils aient évolué depuis plusieurs
années sur ce sujet partant du constat
que la loi actuelle n'est pas suffisante
ce qui a été abondamment développée
fruit d'une réflexion pour aboutir tout
d'abord aux seuils d'âge de 13 ans et
non de 15
la différence d'âge est ici suffisamment
significative pour répondre à l'une des
critiques du conseil d'état lors de
l'élaboration de la loi de 2018 flux
fruit d'une réflexion ensuite pour
savoir s'il était plus pertinent de
partir de la définition actuelle du viol
pour l'améliorer et si comme il est
proposé dans la ppl de notre collègue
annick billon il était préférable de
créer une infraction autonome comme l'a
dit eliane assassi dans son intervention
général les mots ont du sens et un poids
symbolique et parlé de crime sexuel ou
de tout acte de pénétration sexuelle
plutôt que de viol ni pour une part la
violence de l'acte ce qui n'est pas
nommé n'existe pas dit-on souvent
et je crois très important pour les
victimes de poser un mot précis sur ce
qu'elles ont subi
de plus cela reviendrait à voir deux
types différentes d'infraction selon
qu'elle est commise sur un majeur ou sur
un mineur enfin et c'est l'avancée
majeure selon nous du dispositif que
nous proposons c'est la création d'une
profonde une présomption de contrainte
cette présomption irréfragable porterait
uniquement sur l'un des éléments
constitutifs à savoir la contrainte pour
caractériser un viol cette rédaction
mettant le faux tu le focus pardon sur
l'auteur des faits et non sur la victime
permettrait de ne plus interrogé sur un
soi-disant consentement il s'agit pour
nous de façon très claire de dire que la
contrainte est forcément présumés entre
un majeur
mineure de 13 ans que le rapport de
force sans forcément être physique est
de fait existant est défavorable aux
mineurs pour nous cette rédaction
présente au moins deux avantages
tout d'abord elle tient compte là aussi
du risque d'anticonstitutionnalité en
préservant la présomption d'innocence à
laquelle nous sommes attachés
ensuite elle nous paraît plus précises
moins sujettes à l'interprétation que la
loi schiappa qui si elle aussi partait
de la définition du viol évoqué pour
caractériser la contrainte ou la
surprise l'abus de vulnérabilité de la
victime et le discernement nécessaire
pour ces actes notion plus floue
donc voila nous évoluons justement grâce
au débat et je veux remercier
effectivement pour la rédaction de notre
examen de personnalité edouard durant
juge pour enfants à bobigny et ernestine
ronai présidente de l'observatoire des
violences faites aux femmes de saint
denis tous les deux responsables de la
commission genre du haut conseil à
l'égalité je vous remercie chers
collègues mme amara porter sur ces trois
amendements merci monsieur le président
on j'ajoute aussi tout mon respect et
mon admiration à ces deux personnalités
que vous ne citez que nous avions il
assure 10 youn et alors ces amendements
en fête et propose de modifier la
définition du viol pour prévoir une
présomption irréfragable
quand les faits sont commis sur un
mineur de de 15 ans cette présomption
avait été débattue en 2018 comme nous en
avons déjà beaucoup parler et écarté en
raison du peu de problèmes de
constitutionnalité
notre collègue députée alessandra louis
a interrogé plusieurs experts à
l'occasion de son rapport d'évaluation
de la loi schiappa ils lui ont confirmé
que cette voie était juridiquement
risque et où on ne peut pas l'ignorer
c'est juridiquement un risque de chute
aux jurés dire qu'on est tous d'accord
on veut tous faire avancer la cause de
la protection des enfants
on peut il faut quand même faire
attention à ce qu'on écrit il faut faire
attention à ce qu'on vote
donc c'est la création d'une infraction
au code autonome c'est ce qui a été
retenu par notre collègue anny bey
donc elles rencontrent moins de
critiques sur le plan constitutionnel je
pense que vraiment elle a plus de
chances d'aboutir
et je vous propose donc de privilégier
cette voie donc c'est un retrait demande
de retrait ou avis défavorable merci
monsieur le ministre c'est le président
ou supposés dans la commission des lois
même la reporter on saurait mieux dire
en effet que ce qui vient d'être dit à
l'instant je veux vraiment m'exprimer
sur l'amendement trois ans rectifier et
sur les deux autres ensuite sur cet
amendement
c'est une demande de retrait pourquoi
parce que il ya un véritable danger qui
tient au fait qu' on ne peut pas
instaurer une présomption de contraintes
irréfragable ce n'est pas possible c'est
la négation
on l'a dit tout à l'heure et et de la
présomption d'innocence et de tous les
principes qui sont les nôtres on m'a dit
rogatoire c'est c'est c'est un recul à
l'évidence de notre droit le
gouvernement ne ne peux pas être
favorable à un tel amendement et j'ai
entendu ce que vous vous le suggérez
tout à l'heure naturellement la navette
nous allons forcément la respecter c'est
bien la moindre des choses et dont ce
temps qu'on te disais précipitation je
n'envisageais justement pas de d'étirer
les choses mais pendant cette période de
navettes par exemple le garde des sceaux
adrien paquin nous avons l'intention de
consulter encore et on voit bien quand
on entend madame la rapporteure
s'exprimer que il ya un certain nombre
de difficultés qui ne sont pas encore
tranchées
je les énumérer tout à l'heure donc nous
ne sommes pas en défense de ce texte moi
je vous l'entend dire on est favorable à
ce texte
on est favorable à cette idée en défense
moi ici je peux le battre contre ce
texte
je pense qu'il a toutes les raisons
d'être et qu'il est extrêmement utile et
madame jeu j'entends naturellement
souligné la très grande qualité de votre
travail mais je dis que ça nous engage
la par exemple sur la présomption
d'innocence sur des voix il convient de
réfléchir un peu voilà on a vu par le
passé que légiférer sous l'emprise d'une
certaine émotion ce n'était pas toujours
formidable
il faut que l'on ait ce recul suffisant
qu'on réfléchisse qu'on réfléchisse
ensemble et c'est ce que j'espère nous
allons faire c'est donc c'est le même
avis monsieur le ministre sur les deux
identiques ces retraits ou défavorable
donc j'ai des demandes de retrait vous
voyez vous maintenez vos amendements
mais mme kohn aussi un billion juste
deux mots pour dire bien entendu que je
m'oppose à ces amendements tout
simplement parce qu'ils détruisent le
dispositif que j'ai proposé et ce texte
bien entendu monsieur le garde des
sceaux monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
ce texte répond aux écuries qui avaient
été évoqués par le conseil d'état merci
merci donc je vais mais provost à
l'amendement 3 avec deux avis
défavorables commission gouvernement qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adoptée jeu mais je vois les
amendements 4 et 14 identique avec deux
avis défavorables qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adopté l'amendement 11 la même basse à
monsieur le président madame les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues le
présent amendement a pour objet
d'inclure comme crimes sexuels
le rac le rapport bucco-génitales commis
par une personne majeure sur un mineur
ou une mineure dans une récente décision
de la cour de cassation en date du 14
décembre 2020 les magistrats ont écarté
la qualification de viol dans une
affaire d'un 16 parle cunnilingus au
motif que la pénétration vaginale je
suis pas la langue de l'auteur n'aurait
pas été suffisamment intense profonde ou
de longue durée
la jeune fille qui a subi ces abus
sexuels depuis l'âge de 13 ans par son
beau père s'est vu refuser la
qualification de viol et par là même un
procès en cour d'assises
cette décision ne fait que creuser
l'écart entre la réalité des violences
sexuelles commises sur les mineurs et
garçons et filles et leur appréhension
par la justice ces appréciations
inadaptée des magies cela contribue à
une ia cheese ation des viols les
pénétrations digitales les cunnilingus
inflation ne sont dans les faits jamais
pris mina lisez jamais traduit devant
une cour d'assises
sur ce sujet la politique des petits pas
s'avèrent inefficaces
nous l'avons récemment vue suite à la
sphère duhamel plus de six mille tweets
ont été publiées avec la sht admis tout
1,16 dénonçant les violences sexuelles
commises dans le cadre familial
à ce titre en 2020 un français ou une
française sur dix dit avoir été victime
d'inceste violence sur l'enfance selon
une enquête ipsos et il ne s'agit là que
d'une partie des crimes sexuels sur
mineurs montrons notre fermeté
reconnaissons-le at bucco-génitales
comme sur un mineur comme absurdes
mineurs comme un crime sexuel car les
conséquences psychotraumatiques sont les
mêmes pour toutes les victimes
je voudrais mer ce collègue la
rapporteure merci monsieur le président
mes chers collègues je vous je vous
félicite vraiment pour cet amendement
nous avons tous été extrêmement surpris
voire choqués par l'arrêt de la cour de
cassation du mois de décembre avec un
arrêt qui est disons le entre nous
extrêmement glauque
quand on en arrive à discuter sur la
profondeur d'un quart d'un demi
millimètre de quelle façon tourner la
langue pas la langue le doigt palois non
stop stop
donc nous avions dans la dernière loi
fait en sorte que la vie
team pouvait est l'auteur en fait il
s'agissait d'un garçon donc pour parler
avec les mots sont ceux là on avait mis
la fellation par contre on n'ait pas mis
cunnilingus qui lui aussi peut être
extrêmement choquant pour la jeune fille
et doit donc être considéré comme un
viol
donc je vous remercie de cet abonnement
avec pour lesquelles nous sommes
extrêmement favorable et qui souligne
l'égalité navrante en ce cas entre les
garçons et les filles merci madame
monsieur le ministre
oui j'ai fait l'analyse de l'arrêt rendu
par la cour de cassation
mes conclusions sur cet arrêt ne sont
pas du tout les vôtres en réalité la
cour de cassation a simplement valider
le raisonnement des juges du fond et ce
qui est en exergue c'est les éléments de
preuves qui ont été soumis aux juges du
fond pour le reste les gestes du corps
génitaux les rapports bucco-génitaux
quel qu'il soit
quels qu'ils soient peuvent être
qualifiés viol par notre jury feu danse
c'est la raison pour laquelle je propose
un retrait sinon un juge et un autre à
lyon mais il ya de la juriste ou dans
les jeux peu là je peux vous la fournir
les services ont toutes la jurisprudence
qu'il s'agisse de fellation qu'ils
s'agissent de cunnilingus
pour citer les choses par leur nom
peuvent faire l'objet d'une
qualification devient ça arrive très
régulièrement et la jurisprudence
consacre cette position merci donc je
mets aux voix cet amendement on savait
qu'un avis favorable de la commission un
avis défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour et qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté un amendement 12 madame
rossignol
il s'agit par cet amendement de préciser
et de trancher sur la question du seuil
d'âge 13 ans et le l'âge retenu par la
proposition de loi de la ligue billon je
propose avec un sens de mes collègues le
seuil de 15 ans pour plusieurs raisons
la première c'est une pour un temps dans
un souci de cohérence du droit pénal
cohérence du droit pénal le seuil
délictuel retenu pour l'atteinte
sexuelle est de 15 ans pourquoi
faudrait-il avoir un seuil lorsqu'il
s'agit d'une qualification délictuelle
qui serait de 15 ans et de 13 ans
lorsqu'il s'agit d'une qualification
criminelle
je ne retiens pas l'argument d'une
éventuelle inconstitutionnalité parce
que la constitutionalité elle pourrait
être autant valable pour 13 pour la
dimension délictuelle que pour la
dimension criminelle ça c'est la
première fois marque donc il faut avoir
des sols le plus cohérent possible quand
on parle d'infractions sexuelles
j'aurais donné une autre deux autres
éléments quand je parle de cohérence des
seuils je voudrais évoquer la loi
concernant l'achat de services sexuels
donc les clients de la prostitution sur
les mineurs sujet qui nous mobilise
énormément y compris monsieur taquet je
le sais que prévoit la loi la loi
prévoit que le client d'une prostituée
mineure et à une peine aggravée et quand
la prostituée mineure
à moins de 15 ans la peine est encore
aggravée ce qui revient à dire que une
prostituée mineure de moins de 15 ans
pourrait se voir qualifier de viol si
elle a moins de 13 ans sert plutôt
prenant joué à l'envers
disons le autrement le client serait
accusé de viol si la prostituée à moins
de 13 ans mais ne pourraient pas être
poursuivis pour viol
si la prostituée entre 13 et 15 ans or
nous sommes tous unanimes pour
considérer que la prostitution des
mineurs et la même si monsieur monsieur
monsieur dupont moretti je sais que vous
avez pas beaucoup d'attention pour les
lois sur la prostitution
n'hésitez pas à la regarder c'est pas
une note vous soutenez mais néanmoins
elle prévoit une qualification pénale
spécifique pour les clients de moins de
15 ans enfin je crains que en fixant le
seuil à 13 ans
on fragilise les 13 15 ans pour lesquels
on admettra en fin de compte qu'on peut
discuter d'un éventuel consentement
qu'il n'y aurait pas violent entre 13 et
15 ans systématiquement ce que nous
voulons pour les moins de 13 ans nous
devons le vouloir aussi pour les moins
de 15 ans et je conclurai en disant je
crains que dans deux ans nous nous
retrouvions les mêmes à modifier la loi
et pour retenir cette fois ci le seuil
de 15 ans parce que nous aurons eu de
nombreuses affaires qui nous auront
prouvé qu'elle est inopérante et c'est
chaud quand j'ai cherché une mineure de
15 13 15 ans merci maala rapporteur
oui merci président bon je pense qu'en
fait il faut aussi laisser aux lois le
temps un petit peu de s'impliquer de
vivre comme un loup est chez pac n'a que
deux ans celle-ci je l'espère va être
voté pour à vivre un petit peu donc
l'idée dany billon c'est ce crime
autonome de 13 ans je pense que c'est
cela que nous sommes en train de voter
pour le moment ses 13 ans merci donc
avis défavorable monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le président d'avoir moi je
ne m'autorise pas des considérations
d'ordre personnel peu importe sur la
question qui nous occupe et qui est la
seule question qui me préoccupe à cet
instant sommes sur une position de
retrait jeu je vous indiquais qu' il ya
un vrai risque constitutionnel inhérents
au chahut de 15 ans déjà identifiés par
le conseil d'état dans son avis du 15
mars 2018 qui consiste dans le fait
qu'un mineur notamment 17 ans et demi
ils ont eu des relations avec un mineur
de 14 ans deviendrait des facteurs un
criminel le jour de ses 18 ans
ça n'est pas une question tranche elle
est difficile et délicate
ça mérite une vraie réflexion en
approfondissement de nos travaux il ya
déjà un certain nombre de notions qui
sont importantes notamment la
présomption irréfragable que j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure et nous sommes sur une
position de retrait sans polémique
merci mais ses soeurs
l'ia micro et tapoter merci monsieur le
président monsieur messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je voulais
soutenir fortement cet amendement de
madame laurence rossignol en faisant
observer que l'argument le plus fort
c'est le fait que si la loi est votée en
l'état on fragilise considérablement la
situation des personnes de 13 à 15 ans
premièrement et deuxièmement vous vous
exprimerez mes chers collègues et
deuxième manche voulait revenir sur les
deux arguments qui ont été opposés à cet
amendement
le premier monsieur le garde des sceaux
consiste à craindre une décision du
conseil constitutionnel
on n'a jamais autant parlé du conseil
constitutionnel que depuis qu'on discute
ce proche de cette proposition de loi le
conseil constitutionnel il s'exprime
quand il est saisi mais à ce stade c'est
le parlement qui doit faire pleinement
son travail deuxièmement madame le
rapporteur je trouve que l'argument sur
lequel il faut laisser vivre les lois et
quelque peu singulier parce que de deux
choses l'une où la proposition de 15 ans
que nous soutenons est bonne et dans ce
cas pourquoi ne pas l'adopter
faut-il fonctionner par étapes laisser
vivre le texte législatif
cependant que les personnes en subirait
les défaits des effets incomplets ou
négatif je vous remercie
merci cher collègue monsieur aubert pour
l'inspiration d'autres
le président monsieur mini chers
collègues je soutiendrai l'amendement de
laurence rossignol
ce que je ne comprends pas ce chiffre de
13 ans et nous sommes parlementaire nous
sommes des des relais de transmission
entre les territoires
le parlement pour apporter notre
contribution auprès du gouvernement
nous sommes à l'écouté les gens que je
rencontre ne comprennent pas ce fils de
13 ans et ont le sentiment que c'est un
recul merci c'est malveillant
merci monsieur le président moi
j'entends le débat du 13 ans du 15 ans
faut pas oublier qu'il ya deux ans il
n'y avait aucun seuil possible à ce qu'à
inscrire dans la dans la loi donc déjà
voté le 13 ans c'est un progrès
lorsqu'on dit qu'il ya une cohérence
ben oui 13 ans il ya aussi une cohérence
avec la responsabilité pénale la
création d'une infraction autonome
balaye les réserves du conseil d'état de
l'époque donc ça c'est quand même une
information majeure
et n'oublions pas puisque certain nombre
de nos interlocuteurs et la délégation
aux droits des femmes auditionne très
régulièrement le chien dont font partie
bien entendu et le juge edward durand et
ernestine ronai 13 ans
c'est le seuil qui était défendu par le
h est donc chers collègues voter présent
c'est déjà un progrès sociétal important
j'entends les débats mais aussi
accordons aussi pour se dire que treize
c'est un progrès merci monsieur bresson
le citoyen que je suis dirais comme
madame rossignol 15 ans mais le
parlementaire monsieur garde des sceaux
que je suis en responsabilité et c'est
pour cela que je vous demandais tout à
l'heure de faire confiance au travail du
parlement et vous y avez répondu et je
vous en remercie
le parlementaire jeu si au vu de ce que
vient de dire a dit bio restera sur la
position du texte est au restera treize
ans mais ces débats se poursuivront les
choses évolueront et le parlement
certainement au à nouveau l'occasion de
travailler sur ce sur cette situation
c'est ainsi il faut que nous soyons en
face
avec notre société avec l'évolution des
textes et c'est bien en cela que dans
l'hémicycle ici et à l'assemblée
nationale que tu avances et que travail
la loi nous sommes tellement loin des
débats 2018
nous avons tellement avancé et nous
continuerons d'avancer merci chers
collègues dont je me revois l'amendement
12 avec un double avis défavorable
commission gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 27 février
oui merci monsieur le président ce mini
speicher collègues
cet amendement étant la criminalisation
de tout acte de pénétration sexuelle à
ceux commis sur des mineures atteints
d'une déficience psychique jusqu'à 16
ans il s'appuie sur des constats
réalisés ces dernières années par divers
travaux sénatoriaux tout d'abord le
rapport de marie mercier michel meunier
de nigériens sur la répression des
infractions sexuelles sur mineures de
mai 2019
on y lit notamment que selon marie
rabatel confondre à tisser présente de
l'association francophone des femmes
autistes les enfants en situation de
handicap en partie gantés en particulier
mentale ont quatre fois plus de risques
de subir des violences sexuelles que les
autres la commission s'en sont créés aux
pays bas en avril 2010 donc était
parvenu à un ordre de grandeur
comparable en évaluant que les enfants
souffrant d'un déficit de développement
ou dan un cap mental sont trois fois
plus souvent victimes d'abus sexuels que
les autres enfin le rapport de la
délégation aux droits des femmes
d'octobre 2010 9 ceux des violences
faites aux femmes handicapées
il cite notamment une récente enquête
qui estime à près de 47 % la part des
filles autiste de moins de 14 ans qui
aurait subi une agression sexuelle
les lions sexuels sur mineurs atteints
d'un handicap d'origine psychique
doivent ainsi être mieux encadrée par la
loi pénale cet amendement a pour
objectif de sensibiliser à la fois le
gouvernement et notre haute assemblée 6e
cette effroyable situation donc ce fait
de société les agressions sexuelles dans
le nom du handicap
nous devons collectivement nous saisir
de ce sujet et madame la rapporteure
merci mon cher collègue de nous proposer
cet amendement effectivement nous
trouvons devant deux cas de deux femmes
handicapées donc vulnérable et c'est
particulièrement révoltant justement que
ce soient des femmes en situation les
hommes en situation de handicap
donc je vous remercie infiniment de nous
avoir proposé c'est cet amendement je
pense qu'il faut vraiment que ce sujet
qu'il mérite une réflexion plus
approfondie parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
sortes de handicaps de handicaps mentaux
en l'occurrence que le saison n'est
peut-être pas l'âge encore on parle
beaucoup d'âge alors que je suis
personnellement et vous le savez pas
vraiment attachés à l'âge parce que je
pense pour moi pour moi que chaque
personne un développement qui
particulier et qui n'est pas lié à sa
date anniversaire mais bon ça c'est une
une conviction très profonde donc merci
d'avoir amené ce sujet ce matin c'est un
sujet très difficile grave compliquée
mais que nous devons absolument essayer
de résoudre et je vous demanderai de le
retirer non pas qu'ils ne sont pas
importants et que justement il est
tellement important qu'ils méritent
qu'on s'y attache beaucoup plus merci
monsieur ministre merci merci monsieur
le président monsieur le sénateur je
m'inscris totalement dans les propos de
madame la rapporteure je partage aussi
ses remerciements d'avoir porté ce sujet
et sujet qui doit geler dit dans la
déclaration générale nous occuper encore
beaucoup je pense dans les semaines et
les mois à venir
c'est un sujet complexe
on a parlé de tabous deux derniers
tabous s'agissant de l'inceste
on va pas faire de hiérarchie entre les
différents crimes enfin quand on va
commencer à parler d'un c est
effectivement sur les enfants en
situation de handicap
je pense que là on sera saisi une fois
encore de l'horreur auquel un certain
nombre d enfants sont de nos enfants
sont confrontés
je suis totalement d'accord avec madame
la rapporteure et je pense que marié
rabatel et je vous remercie aussi de
l'avoir de la voir citez moi c'est elle
qui m'a quand j'étais député à l'époque
qui m'a sensibilisé sur la question des
violences sur les femmes en situation de
handicap les violences sexuelles
notamment ce n'est pas une question
d'âge en réalité c'est une question de
discernement c'est une question c'est
une question de généralités quand on est
notamment une personne avec un trouble
du spectre de l'autisme la question du
consentement n'a pas du tout la même
signification n'est pas du tout vécu de
la même façon que vous et moi
voilà mais ce n'est pas une question
d'âge
question qui relève du nord au
développement et c'est comme ça voilà
donc je ne pense pas qu effectivement la
question d'une réponse par le seuil
d'âge que vous apportez soit soit d'une
part la bonne réponse et puis mais vous
le savez très bien
là aussi il y à une entièreté une
complexité du sujet abordé comment
libérer la parole on parle beaucoup de
libération de la parole comment libérer
la parole d'un enfant avec autisme non
verbale ça c'est un sujet que nous
devons nous poser comment faire en sorte
de libérer la parole d'un enfant en
situation de handicap avec déficience
mentale par exemple qui est dans un
institution
voilà comment comment faisons en sorte
que ces enfants là une fois encore ne
reste pas sur le bord de la route de ce
mouvement de société formidable qui est
en train d'opérer et que nous devons
accompagner mais n'oublions pas ces
enfants là voilà mais je ne doute pas
que nous aurons l'occasion avec my
rabaté avec les associations avec vous
même de travailler sur ces sujets merci
à une demande de retrait donc une
demande de retrait mais février oui je
vais retirer cet amendement simplement
monsieur ministre j'entends vos
explications et je ne peux que vous
inviter à vous saisir plus fortement de
ce sujet là je pense et je pourrais même
justifier une mission particulière
transversale à travers des différents
ministères pour qu'on nous puissions
justement mettre sur la table
cette particularité qui ne peut pas être
traité dans ce texte là mais je voulais
vraiment profité de cette ouverture de
cette fenêtre pour en parler ici
publiquement
merci l'amendement 27 et donc retirer
nos passions à l'amendement 17 la madame
de la montrer merci président cet
amendement est très important dans ce
texte nous avons décidé de fixer un
seuil d'âge avec une infraction
spécifique le seuil d'âge de 13 ans il
vient d'être débattue mais nous ne
fixons pas de seuil d'âge spécifique
pour l'inceste l'inceste
nous proposons donc lorsqu'il s'agit
d'une victime mineure de 18 ans ce soit
inclus dans cette infraction spécifique
et que ce soit criminalisée parce
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas prétendre
que l'inceste n'est pas poursuivre que
pénales ce serait inexact mais ce n'est
qu'une circonstance aggravante des
agressions sexuelles et du viol et donc
on retombe comme toujours
dans la question du consentement la
contrainte la surprise la violence bref
vous en connaissez les données donc ce
que nous affirmons par ce texte c'est
que moins de 18 ans inceste crime et
c'est très important que ce soit voté
aujourd'hui et c'est pour cela je l'aï
indiqué dans mon intervention lors de la
discussion générale que mon groupe va
demandé un scrutin public sur ce sur ce
texte parce que certes l'actualité fait
que ce sujet ressort mais l'actualité
permanente de manière permanente on nous
parle de cas d'inceste
cela fait que quelques années que
l'inceste est identifié dans le code
pénal
donc il ne faut pas avoir avoir peur des
situations craindre les mots moins de 18
ans inceste égale crime
c'est l'occasion aujourd'hui pour le
sénat de l'affirmer merci chers
collègues donc tout le monde a entendu
qu'il y aura scrutin public donc que ce
je demande à chaque groupe de préparer
ce scrutin public mme amara porter la
vie la commission merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues donc cet
amendement propose de considérer comme
un crime tout acte de pénétration
sexuelle commis par un match sur un
mineur jusqu'à 18 ans quand la relation
présente un caractère incestueux
seraient concernées les parents aux
premier deuxième et troisième degré
c'est-à-dire les parents grands parents
frères et soeurs neveux et nièces et
oncles et tantes serait également
concerné le conjoint ou le concubin ou
le partenaire lié par un pacs de l'une
des personnes précédemment c'est
mentionné
si je vous dis tout ça c'est important
souhait écoutez bien je comprends
l'intention des auteurs de cet
amendement
mais je m'interroge beaucoup sur la
constitutionnalité d'un tel dispositif
au regard de la nécessité de
caractériser l'élément intentionnel du
délit
soyons concret actuellement un mineur de
plus de 15 ans peut avoir des rapports
sexuels consentis avec un majeur on est
tous d'accord avec ce dispositif
si on a une mineure de 17 ans et demi
qui a un jour un rapport consenti avec
le concubin de sa soeur pourquoi pas
inouï qui n'a peut être que quelques
années de plus cette relation elle
enverra automatiquement le dit concubin
aux assises parce que la soirée serait
pas contente du tout vous imaginez bien
alors qu'ils n'ont aucun lien de sang et
a priori surtout aucun rapport
d'autorité dont il aurait pu abuser
c'est un écart d'un contrat si je puis
dire alors sa peau peuvent régler
gentiment sans aller aux assises l'a
donc à tel dispositif me paraît poser un
sérieux problème au regard du respect
des droits de la défense et du principe
de nécessité des délits et des peines je
vais continuer en dix ans pour le que la
commission a en revanché émis un avis
favorable à l'amendement 25 que vous
présentez et qu'on va examiner dans
quelques instants
non c'est pas incohérent l'écart ce
second amendement ils posent moins de
problèmes
il introduit une circonstance aggravante
sur un délit le seuil d'âge n'est pas le
même et le périmètre retenu pour
qualifier l'inceste est beaucoup mieux
défini donc la commission elle est prête
à à bien sûr avancer sur la question de
l'inceste mais nous devons faire avec
rigueur sur le plan juridique
au risque de décevoir les victimes elles
mêmes
merci monsieur le ministre c'est pour
moi une époustouflante démonstration des
difficultés que l'on peut avoir quand
c'est pas quels mots utiliser maintenant
je suis toujours très attentif quand
vous êtes là je vous sais tellement
vigilante tellement aimable tellement
vigilante que je suis toujours très
attentif à la mme de la gontrie
mais voyez-vous quand j'évoque eilat
quand j'ai évoqué le besoin de réfléchir
tendu oui les exemples qui ont été
fournies par là même la reporter je suis
convaincu vous n'y aviez pas songé et
pourtant et aubin non parce que vous
auriez vous n'auriez pas présenté cet
amendement
donc c'est une aimable demandes de
retraits que je fais parce que ça
effectivement ça nous parle l'idée c'est
pas de renvoyer aux assises à
l'emporte-pièce pardonnez moi ça n'est
pas le but de la loi pénale
j'ai essayé de dire tout à l'heure avec
les mots qu'ils étaient les biens on y
avait vu une forme de réticences pas du
tout je vous redis ici que nous
souhaitons travailler mais pleinement
avec vous sur ce texte
mais voilà le genre d'exemples qui doit
nous interdire d'aller sur cet
amendement
je vous propose un retrait masséna prise
merci même la présidente rossignol
président
d'abord une remarque j'ai l'impression
que c'est inconstitutionnel est devenu
in the new je ne suis pas d'accord c'est
à dire que à chaque fois que l'un ou
l'autre n'est pas d'accord avec une
proposition que nous faisons est
particulièrement comme le faisait
remarquer tout d'ailleurs jean pierre
sueur sur ces sujets c'est
inconstitutionnel
moi je ne connais qu'une façon de savoir
c'est quelque chose et qu'on sociale ou
pas c'est que le conseil constutionnel
se prononce et le fait en général en ce
qui concerne l'amendement qui nous est
soumis de quoi on parle depuis quelques
années de consentement et d'emprise de
quoi s'agit-il en matière d'inceste de
consentement et d'emprise qui pense
sérieusement que l'emprise s'arrête à 15
ans qu'elle ne va pas jusqu'à la
majorité et parfois même au delà mais
nous ne pouvons parfois les mots de là
mais nous ne pouvons pas le gérer je
vais vous raconter une histoire
dans mon département dans une commune
voisine de la mienne
il ya une dizaine d'années un père et sa
fille ont été le père a été poursuivi il
violait ses trois filles il a été
condamné à deux ans de prison
ces mêmes il a fait deux ans de prison
peu après il est parti avec sa fille ils
ont eu un enfant et puis après la fille
l'a quitté il a tué la fille et le
pauvre garagiste chez laquelle il était
hébergé qu'avaient plaidé à cette époque
les avocats l'inceste
e l'inceste consenti cet amendement il
vise qu'à une chose c'est que plus
jamais on ne parle d'inceste euros est
consentie devant une cour d'assises
merci madame carrière oui merci monsieur
le président comme j'ai pu le dire dans
la discussion générale tout à l'heure le
groupe rdse avait déposé en 2019 une ppr
visant engagé par d'eau visant à engager
diverses mesures pour intensifier la
lutte et la prévention sur la question
de l'inceste et c'est françoise laborde
hauteur de 7 ppr et vous connaissez tous
son engagement et son travail sur ce
sujet qui rappelait combien dans ce
texte qui rappelait dans ce texte
combien il était important de faire
évoluer le droit pénal pour reconnaître
à sa juste valeur la gravité du
traumatisme subi par les victimes
d'inceste les conséquences sur l'enfant
sont prouvés sur le plan neurobiologie
comportementale cognitif et affectif
elle estimait aussi qu'en matière
d'inceste la reconnaissance du non
consentement devrait être un principe
inaliénable
concernant les mineurs limite d'âge ou
pas aujourd'hui
l'inceste sans être nommés est considéré
comme une circonstance aggravante
cette définition générale ne correspond
ni à la réalité ni à la complexité des
implications pour les victimes
et c'est pour ces raisons que le groupe
rdse votera cet amendement considérant
que c'est un pas important
merci merci chers collègues donc je vais
mettre au roi l'amendement 17 avec un
double avis défavorable j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe socialiste et que je sers appétit
horaires républicain pardon sur
l'amendement 17
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par atik 56
du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
résultat du scrutin à 56 sur
l'amendement 17 compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordés par les sénateurs groupes
politiques et notifié la présidence
nombre de votants 343 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 326 pour l'adoption
97 contre 229 le sénat n'a pas adopté
je mets ouvre à l'article 1er qui pour
l'article 1er qui et contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté ces présidents
avaient fait président si le ministre
sir collègues le rapporteur jean de
faire simplement d'observation générale
à chaque fois que à se vendre
un rapporteur quel qu'il soit tu évoques
le principe tout l'idée qu'un amendement
n'a pas de caractère constitutionnel
c'est pas pour essayer de contourner
l'obstacle ou essayer de renvoyer à plus
tard
un sujet ou un autre c'est parce que
c'est le résultat d'une analyse
juridique fait par la commission
notamment et singulièrement par la
commission des lois
donc il y a une constitution
vous savez tous il ya une jurisprudence
et que nul n'est censé ignorer la
jurisprudence
donc c'est à partir de cela que c'est
comme cela que nous fonctionnons s'il
advenait qu'on se fiche totalement de la
jurisprudence et je parle très librement
alors à ce moment là je crains que le
conseil constitutionnel en arrivions à
faire quasiment presque je n'ose pas
dire mais presque n'importe quoi et à
sont là ça n'a plus de sens mais ça
n'aurait plus de sens ça ne veut pas
dire que par moments il faut pas savoir
éventuellement bouger les choses mais
cela relève d'un autre débat et d'une
autre démarche
en tous les cas je tiens à rappeler que
ce qu'a dit madame le rapporteur au
sujet de la qualification d'un certain
nombre d'amendements et de l'analyse sur
le fond je parle sur le fond ont été
faits naturellement avec beaucoup de
précision et beaucoup de réflexion avant
de tenir ce fronton merci merci monsieur
la tique additionnel après l'article 1er
l'amendement 13 manière merci monsieur
le président messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
la notion d'autorité à cela de flou dans
notre société codifiée qu'elle génère
des normes et des comportements induits
par la place que nous occupons
ainsi pour chacune et chacun l'autorité
bien une relation de pouvoir qui
s'exerce ou qui se subit il y a bien
évidemment différent niveau d'autorité
celle très codifié que produit la loi
c'est le plus
explique qui explicite du monde du
travail qui s'exprime par un
organigramme et puis celle plus
individuelle et plus intrinsèque que
l'on trouve chez les personnes dont on
dit d'elle qu'elle dispose d'une
autorité naturelle
enfin il y à celle qui nous intéresse
plus précisément ici au regard des
débats qui nous anime
celle d'un adulte qui s'applique
implicitement sur l'enfant ainsi
l'ascendant ce dont dispose
naturellement un adulte sur un enfant de
par son âge constitue en soi une
autorité et que dire lorsqu'il s'agit
d'un viol incestueux ou d'emblée
l'autorité est institutionnalisée par le
code civil en tant qu autorité parentale
pour autant
l'interprétation de cette notion
d'autorité par les juges gagnerait à
être affinés c'est ce que propose cet
amendement nous souhaitons définir plus
précisément cette autorité constitutive
de la contrainte en matière d'agressions
sexuelles ou de viols en s'appuyant
notamment sur le rapport du haut conseil
à l'égalité celui ci dans son rapport
pour une juste condamnation sociétal du
viol évoque je cite certaines disposent
ici certaines décisions de justice qui
constitue la seule existence de relation
d'autorité a caractérisé la contrainte
donc voilà cet amendement propose de
remplacer exerce l'autorité exercée sur
la victime en a sur la victime afin de
lever le flou sur tech notion d'autorité
merci madame le rapporteur merci
monsieur le président oui effectivement
vous proposer cette harmonisation de
remplacer exerce par a
je suis pas certaine que cette
modification sémantique et modifier
l'état du droit mais j'observe qu'elle
permettrait d'harmoniser effectivement
le vocabulaire employé dans le code
pénal
il est généralement fait mention de la
personne qui a autorité
donc il n'est pas absurde d'harmoniser
donc avis favorable merci monsieur
ministre le gouvernement s'en remet à la
sagesse de la haute assemblée
merci donc je mets au voile amendement
13 avec un avis favorable de la
commission en a il s'agissait du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'obtient est adopté nous pouvons
passer peut-être l'amendement 5
ben voyons finement il s'agit
d'envisager qu'avant l'âge de 15 ans et
mineur peut consentir à des relations
sexuelles avec un partenaire mineur si
celui ci est de moins de deux ans son
aîné qui n'exercent aucune relation
d'autorité de dépendance sous quelques
formes d'exploitation que ce soit son
endroit
merci maintenant porter haut avec des
sioux c'est vrai qu'on ferait quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de choses
bon le débat est très intéressant or on
le sait il y adeux ce qu'on appelle des
petits couples des jeunes couples bon
qui ont des relations consenties
tout le monde le sait donc ce débat est
intéressant mais moi je crois qu'il est
vraiment hasardeux de le trancher là au
détour de l'examen d'une ppl par pas de
constitutionnel pas là c'est un autre
objet la ppl de notre collègue annie
billon donc je comprends bien vraiment
bien cette cette idée mais je pense que
c'est un autre sujet qu'il faut le
réfléchir donc elles ont des favoris au
retrait ou défavorable le sionisme même
avis un avis de retrait en ce qui
concerne le gouvernement et on en
revient à ce que nous avons dit à de
nombreuses reprises ce qui est partagé
c'est la difficulté de trancher les
choses pour ce que sur ce point
on propose évidemment vous proposer une
piste de réflexion qui est extrêmement
intéressante autour de l'écart d'âge et
comme je vais exploser tout à l'heure je
demande à mes services d'expertisé cela
encore un peu le temps de la clac la
navette peut-être merci me voyez il est
mature retirer il est retiré
l'amendement 5 et retiré après l'article
1er un amendement numéro 20 sec
présenté par madame de la gontrie merci
président en un mot il s'agit de
réprimer plus durement les atteintes
sexuelles sur mineures de manière à
pouvoir les intégrer dans l'article déjà
créé par ce texte et il a reçu je ne
veux pas empiéter sur temps de parole de
la rapporteure un avis favorable de la
commission
sans pour autant répondent d'ailleurs à
la préoccupation que nous avons eues
avant la pause déjeuner concernant le
crime d'inceste
avis de la commission complète le droit
avis favorable gouvernement a vite ses
gestes selon doute quelques difficultés
rédactionnelle mais on est d'accord sur
le sens de cet amendement n'a pas
d'explications de vote
je mets aux voix quels sont ceux qui
sont pour quels sont ceux qui sont
coffre qu'ils s'abstiennent l'amendement
est adopté
alors s'il te promis bis un amendement
numéro 19 présenté au signal
oui merci monsieur le président cette
article 1er bis d'abord traduit les
difficultés et même des ambiguïtés dans
le raisonnement de ceux qui ont choisi
de retenir un seuil de 13 ans puisque
les auteurs se sentent obligés et de
prévoir une disposition spécifique pour
la victime âgés entre 13 et 15 ans pour
cédric image n 13 et 15 ans il est donc
proposé par cet article 1er bis nouveau
de modifier la définition de la
contrainte morale en prévoyant que elle
peut être utilisée lorsque la victime à
moins de 15 ans ils disposent dit ne
dispose pas de la majorité sexuelle
suffisante
premièrement la contrainte morale peut
déjà être utilisé pour toutes
circonstances et particulièrement l es
quand tu es un écart d'âge ou lorsque la
victime est pas en état de donner son
consentement et par ailleurs elle
introduit une disposition que nous
avions déjà combattu en première lecture
celle de la majorité sexuelle de la
maturité par nonce excellent suffisante
et je crains que cette disposition qui
est plein de bonnes intentions puisque
elle vise à être au plus fin auprès des
victimes et d'imaginer qu'à des victimes
plus ou moins mûrs en fait une
disposition qui se retourne et qu'ils
soient al'avantage des auteurs qui
pourront argue effectivement de la magie
de la maturité sexuelle de la victime
ce n'est pas une bonne conversation de
discuter de savoir si une enfant de
treize ou un enfant de 13 à 15 ans a ou
non la maturité sexuelle d'une relation
avec un adulte je vais à cet instant
cité camille kouchner qui disait quand
l'enfant ne dit pas non
c'est à l'adulte de dire non tenons nous
tenons nous en l' avis de la commission
merci monsieur le président donc vous me
demandez de supprimer cet article
je reprend l'histoire annie billon fait
une ppl pour protéger les enfants de
moins de 13 ans vous vouliez aller
jusqu'à 15 ans moi je trouve que le
seuil d'âge c'est quelque chose de
compliqué j'ai vraiment 13 ans et un
jour pour moi c'est comme 13 ans moins
un jour donc là je propose justement de
d'étendre cette protection au 13 15 en
gardant la flexibilité en gardant la
façon d'appréhender la maturité sexuelle
de la victime qui est différente de la
maturation sexuelle
la maturité sexuelle de la victime donc
non vraiment pour moi il faut justement
garder cette protection des 13-15 qui
colle très bien avec la proposition de
la part de l'avis du gouvernement le
ministre
c'est un avis de sagesse pour le
gouvernement
avec ce pas d'explication d'europe je
vais te vois cet amendement quels sont
ceux qui sont pour
quels sont ceux qui sont contre qui
s'abstiennent l'amendement n'est pas
adopté je me revois l'article 1er bis
quels sont ceux qui sont pour
quels sont ceux qui sont contre qui
s'abstiennent
l'arctique est adopté j'aimais ou voir
l'article 2 quels sont ceux qui sont
tour quels sont ceux qui sont contre qui
s'abstiennent l'article 2 est adopté je
mets au voir l'article 3
quels sont ceux qui sont tour quels sont
ceux qui sont contre qui s'abstiennent
l'arctique est adopté tu me vois leur
cycle le capt quels sont ceux qui sont
pour ceux qui sont contre qui
s'obtiennent l'arctique et adopté après
l'article 4
un amendement vite rectifié père
présenté par merci monsieur le président
je voulais vous parler des nombreuses
victimes de viols qui parle d'un état de
sidération en réaction à langoat
extrêmes subies lors d'un viol ou d'une
violence certains mécanismes de défense
entre en jeu la victime est tétanisé ce
qui lui permet de diminuer sa souffrance
physique et psychique selon la
psychiatre muriel salmona dont nous
citons souvent les travaux la personne
est ainsi paralysé ne peut réagir
ce sont des réactions neurobiologiques
normal du cerveau face à une situation
anormale celle des violences dit elle
pourtant ce phénomène de sidération
reconnu par la psychiatrie est encore
largement ignorée voire contesté la
victime se voit même presque
systématiquement confrontés dans les cas
où elle porte plainte à des questions
sur son absence de réaction face à son
violeur peu de surprises donc à ce
qu'une femme victime de viol sur dix
seulement portent plainte et qu'une
plainte pour viol sur 10 aboutissent à
une condamnation
c'est pourquoi nous devons envisager
l'état de sidération psychique des
victimes de viol comme une contrainte
morale
vous allez me répondre que l'amnésie
traumatique n'a pas sa place encore dans
notre droit
mais je peux vous
teulé que nous avons votée en juillet la
notion d'emprise manifeste de l'un des
époux sur notre conjoint dans le code
civil
nous venons à l'instant de voter la
notion de maturité sexuelle suffisante
ce qui est une innovation sémantique et
juridique et je dois vous signaler que
le code de la santé publique prévoit une
notion médicale
l'étape à ce traumatisme pour les
militaires c'est le décret de 2009
donc nous sommes bien en face de notions
qui relève de la neuroscience et enfin
les magistrats se font déjà sur des
expertises en faisant état de sidération
psychique lorsqu ils apprécieront lors
ce qu'ils apprécient par dans
l'existence d'une contrainte dans le cas
d'une infraction à caractère sexuel
aujourd'hui je propose tout simplement
de l'inscrire dans la loi afin que les
jeunes tiennent davantage compte de
l'état de sidération psychique comme
contrainte morale ils pourront retenir
ou pas cette contrainte morale
cela ne remet pas en cause leur
appréciation souveraine mais mon
amendement apportera je le crois un
cadre et enfin une dernière remarque
pour répondre aux critiques jeu
puisqu'elles ont été faites en
commission mais je le redis je vous
précise que cet amendement reprend la
même logique rédactionnelle que celle
qui est prévu l article 222 222 1
la contrainte morale ou la surprise
peuvent résulter de la différence d'âge
existe entre la victime l'auteur des
faits et de l' autorité de droit ou de
fait ce que celui exerce sur la victime
je vous remercie
au vu de la commission merci monsieur le
président ma chère collègue donc je
comprends bien votre intention
mais je voudrais vous dire que quand un
patient ou quand une victime est sidéré
c'est comme si le cerveau se mettait sur
pause pour assurer sa survie
mais on ne peut pas dire que la
contrainte va découler de ça c'est le
contraire s'est elle se met en
sidération
la sidération résulte de cette
contrainte qui lui en fait j'ai bien lu
je jouis j'ai bien lu je comprends ma
consoeur muriel salmona aussi par contre
la rédaction ne correspond pas puisqu'on
se place uniquement du point de vue de
la victime
donc on ne peut pas déduire la
contrainte de la sidération
mais bien évidemment c'est la contrainte
qu'implique la si l'éruption mais pas
dans l'autre sens donc comment vous
parler d' amnésie traumatique bien
évidemment en tant que médecin on peut
subodorer que ça existe et que des
patients et cette réaction
et pour le moment on ne peut pas encore
mettre dans le droit ce qui n'a pas été
prouvée par les neurosciences la loi
n'aura jamais la souplesse de la vie il
faut que ce soit prouvée enfin on ne va
se mettre que du côté de la victime même
si est partout que les fibres de mon
corps je veux défendre les victimes sont
toujours laisser le droit à la défense
et ça je suis désolé mais actuellement
je comprends bien votre intention mais
je ne peux pas donner un avis favorable
si désolée je presse le ministre mais ma
vie à la virgule près pas d'explications
de vote je mettre aux voix cet
amendement quels sont ceux qui sont pour
ce qu'elles sont ceux qui sont contre
on va refaire
quels sont ceux qui sont pour
quels sont ceux qui sont contre
il met pas adopté il te rappelle
l'article 4 un amendement mérovingiens
présenté par madame rossignol vont
adopter un amendement de madame benbassa
sur les rapports bucco génitaux
en ce qui concernait la nouvelle
incrimination de crimes sexuels sur
enfants
je propose pour ma part d'introduire la
même nuance fa la même précision pardon
dans la définition du viol j'en ch et
bien entendu ce qu'a dit monsieur le
garde des sceaux ce matin et c'est vrai
que jusqu'à cette décision de la chambre
criminelle
j'avais toujours considéré que les
rapports bucco-génitaux était inclus
dans la pénétration telle qu'elle est
définie dans l'article du code pénal 222
22,1 sur le viol pour autant après cette
décision de la chambre criminelle et
pour éviter que des juges mal
intentionnées ou des avocats de la
défense s'y réfèrent exceptions sont à
court de la croissance crée rien contre
les avocats et je tout pour les droits
de la défense mais c'est les deux c'est
quand même les deux situations avec elle
en manie le droit les juges et les
avocats et que l'on pourrait imaginer
que cette jurisprudence certes
exceptionnelle la jambe criminels
servent d'appui à d'autres affaires donc
puisqu'il a fallu le préciser pour la
viola l'atteinte paulo crime devient
sexuelle précisons le aussi pour le viol
par cohérence avec ce que nous avons
voté il est à deux heures au lieu de la
commission
par cohérence avis favorable je men et
ça veut dire au revoir
exactement la même position que celle
que j'ai exprimée ce matin c'est normal
c'est cohérent pas d'explications de
vote
je vais mettre aux voix cet amendement
quels sont ceux qui sont pour quels sont
ceux qui sont contre qui s'abstiennent
l'amendement est adopté un amendement de
rectifier oui monsieur le président
merci je me thème la rapporteure c'est
un amendement de signal c'est un signal
envoyé à tous ceux qui se taisent il
s'agit ici d'agrafés en fait les peines
encourues pour non-dénonciation aggravé
les peines d'emprisonnement mais aussi
les les sanctions pécuniaires et
également de renforcer ses sanctions
quand il s'agit d'un d'un abus sur un
mineur de moins de 15 ans a vu de la
commission on a vu sur le délit de non
dénonciation mais votre amendement ma
chère collègue en fait c'est que
l'auteur de l'infraction au principal
vous voilà pourrait être moins punis que
l'auteur du dino signalement donc c'est
un avis défavorable vis du gouvernement
refuse évidemment tout à fait sur la
position d'un rapporteur
il ya une question d'équilibré en
réalité nous avons ici une infraction
est punie une abstention
et si l'on suivait votre amendement tout
l' équilibre viendrait à être
déséquilibré les violences elle-même
pourrait être moins sévèrement punis que
l'abstention que vous dénoncez
légitimement dans ces conditions nous
sommes évidemment défavorable au code
pénal c'est aussi une question d
équilibre et sont souvent d'ailleurs des
équilibres précaires
c'est en ce sens que il faut être
extrêmement attentif on ne touche la loi
pénale que kingdom un tronc blanc tu
je le retire mais c'est le président
obama doit retirer ses 3 un rendement
toujours par l'article 4 à l'article 4
qui font l'objet d'une discussion comme
bing le rectifier père de madame paoli
agen il est satisfait par la commission
et son président le rosé rennes le mans
29 présenté par madame madame merci à la
rapporteure donc nous vous proposons
dans les cas du délit de
non-dénonciation une augmentation du
délai de prescription
quand city s'agirait de ne pas avoir
dénoncé un délit nous le porterions à 10
ans quand il s'agirait de ne pas de
dénoncer un crime nous le porterions à
20 ans sachant qu'actuellement pour les
délits de droit commun mais crible ses
2,6 en un amendement numéro 20 présenté
par madame rossignol ans
je vais retirer l'amendement numéro 20
parce que le 29 de la commission est
beaucoup mieux que le mien est juste une
petite remarque sur nos travaux la
manière dont nous le construisons la
même le même amendement que j'avais
déposé il ya deux ans avait été rejetée
aujourd'hui il va être adopté
si on pouvait anticiper un petit peu sur
ce qu'ils ont à ce qu'on va faire dans
deux ans ce serait bien avide du
gouvernement à l'amendement 29 de la
commission des lois
monsieur le ministre compte tenu de tout
ce que je vous ai dit sur la
prescription c'est une position de
sagesse que celles du gouvernement
mais ce légation l'europe
madame minier merci monsieur président
oui la dénonciation de l'inceste jette
l'opprobe sur la famille considéré comme
le pivot de l'ordre social
voilà en résumé en une phrase pourquoi
certaines personnes expliquent leur
silence face à la connaissance d'un
crime sexuel sur mineur on a peur à
l'heure on se tait on n'est pas victime
mais on a peur de briser une famille
opprobre honte hésitation protection
nous ne pouvons plus accepter cela nous
parlons ici de crime sexuel sur mineur
ces crimes qui détruisent des vies et il
n'y a pas de prescription pour cette
douleur et pour cette souffrance ces
enfants ne s'en remettra jamais l'
atteinte à leur intégrité physique et
morale est souvent définitive les
enfants cohabite avec cette souffrance
toute leur vie alors on préfère
l'ignorer
les victimes n'arrivent pas toujours à
parler à dénoncer car on sait elles ont
peur de ne pas être cru mais qu'en est
il de ceux et de celles qui savent et
qui se taisent la loi impose pourtant de
saisir la justice quand on a
connaissance de faits terribles de crime
rien de plus la loi impose impose aux
proches ni d'instruire ni de juger ou de
sanctionner
de plus en plus fréquemment désormais
nous débattons du cadre législatif qui
entoure les crimes sexuels tous les ans
de nouveaux drames sont médiatisés
soulignons encore le courage de celles
qui révèle
faits et la parole peu à peu qui se
libère qu'attendons nous pour faire pour
combler les lacunes d'un système dès
maintenant nous devons créer un
électrochoc énoncer clairement un
interdit
c'est l'objet de cette proposition de
loi mais aussi rappeler chaque adulte à
ses responsabilités de protection des
enfants ce qu'ils savaient et qui n'ont
rien dit doivent être punis par la loi
lorsque des affaires éclatent les
auteurs sont parfois poursuivi je dis
bien parfois
mais au bout de six ans ce qu'ils
savaient et qui ont maintenu l'enfant
dans cette situation inacceptable
eux ne sont pas poursuivis la parole des
victimes doit être enfin entendus et le
silence interdite c'est la raison pour
laquelle je voudrais cet amendement on
voit cet amendement l'amendement de la
commission des lois qui a reçu un avis
le sagesse du gouvernement quels sont
ceux qui sont pour quels sont ceux qui
sont contre qui s'abstiennent
l'amendement est adopté
après l'article cap
trois amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune dans deux amendements
identiques
le ciss rectifié madame boyer
si monsieur le président je vais aller
vite parce qu'on n'a pas trop le temps
de débattre mais il s'agit
de faire en sorte que le code de
procédure pénale par dérogation les
décisions soit inscrite pour la durée
quelques pas excusez moi
par dérogation que les décisions soit
inscrite quelle que soit la durée de la
peine dès lors que la victime des délits
rentrer dans le cas qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'elle est
mineure est donc ce qui permettrait
aujourd'hui de rendre obligatoire
l'inscription au fnj des personnes
condamnées à des peines même inférieure
à cinq années d'emprisonnement
dès lors que la victime était mineure on
est plusieurs à avoir déposé cet
amendement mais je pense que ça fait
avancer la protection des victimes
même si fier oui à mon tour de présenter
cet amendement qui va dans le même sens
je les déposer à nouveau avec d'autres
collègues je remercie au passage mes
collègues donc c'était en 2016 la
première fois ici pour moi et puis deux
fois en 2018
on l'a évoqué ce matin à mesure que nous
sommes amenés à renforcer notre
législation pour protéger les enfants
des crimes sexuels les arguments safin
et les positions évoluent la question de
la prescription de l'action publique
pour ces viols et agressions sexuelles
sur les enfants et les adolescents en
prix désormais l'opinion publique ce
matin monsieur le ministre taquet nous a
est nommé nommé et
et si tu es toutes ses victimes comme
andrea vanessa adélaïde camille flavie
sahara etc et toutes ces victimes
d'ailleurs je note au passage sont
favorables à l'imprescriptibilité elle
nous montre l'ampleur du crime
son caractère massif un enfant sur cinq
je le répète et plus de 2 millions en
france
ces victimes décrivent la profondeur des
souffrances endurées
leur persistance dans le temps l'un des
seuls crimes pour lesquels la victime
est condamné à vivre avec à survivre
plutôt à vivre mal abîmé éprouvée dans
sa chair affecté de traumatismes qui
nuisent à ses études son insertion
sociale sa réussite professionnelle
l'établissement de relations affectives
stable condamnés parfois à relancer le
cycle de la violence envers ses proches
et ça a été redit ce matin je connais
depuis des années les arguments opposés
à l'imprescriptibilité elle respecte
noël ne respecteraient pas les normes
juridiques en vigueur
eh bien faisons les évolués comme la
californie a su faire suite à la sphère
bill cosby pour lesquels victime
prescrites et victime portant plainte
c'est pollet et crimes contre l'humanité
et pourquoi pas ne pas considérer la tan
sourde et impunies de ces milliers
d'enfants comme une atteinte à leur
humanité donc à notre qualité d'être
humain
a tous je découvre un nouveau arguments
un nouvel argument l'exigence d'une
prescription limitée qui permettrait la
libération de la parole c'est à mon sens
faire peu de cas de des travaux de
l'imagerie médicale et des neurosciences
et des progrès en ce domaine
donc pour ces raisons donnant crédit à
celles qui osent briser le silence et
permettons aux futures victimes de
porter plainte sans limite
le moment dix présentés par là-même
millions merci monsieur le président ça
va être extrêmement court il ya une
deuxième ppl qui a eu la gentillesse
d'inverser le calendrier donc cet
amendement évidemment vise à rallonger
le délai de prescription
il vise à ouvrir le débat bien entendu
je partage tous les arguments qui ont
été énoncées avant et je nous encourage
collectivement
à avancer très vite pour laisser la
place aux textes suivante
merci à lui de la commission l'a
prescrit bilité c'est vrai qu'on serait
interroge toujours sur nos convictions
c'est sûr c'est sûr que la victime et
prend perpétuité c'est vrai mais
pardonnez moi mais même si on n'a pas
beaucoup de temps pour moi la
prescription c'est un acte de parole
j'aime explique moi je me serais d'une
patiente qui m'avait dit il faut il faut
que je me motive je n'ai plus que deux
ans pour aller porter plainte si ça
avait été un prescriptibles je pense
qu'on attend on attend pour finalement
ne plus jamais y aller tellement c'est
douloureux tellement c'est difficile
aussi
et si en plus elle est pas cru et si en
plus elle est pas cru donc vraiment je
pense que prononça prônons la
prescription comme un acte de libération
de la parole et encourageons les
victimes a libéré cette parole avec des
moyens avec des enquêteurs qui ont été
formés etc etc
mais je pense que c'est dans cet axe là
qu'il faut travailler à vis des favoris
du ministre le jury n'est cependant à
vis bien évidemment chez le président
défavorable robert badinter a évoqué
hier le sort des crimes contre
l'humanité il a dit ce qu'il avait à
dire partage son point de vue mais si
nous envisageons l'imprescriptibilité
des crimes qui nous qui nous réunissent
aujourd'hui faudra qu'on envisage
l'imprescriptibilité d'autres crimes
pourquoi par l'imprescriptibilité des
meurtres des assassinats ou il ya aussi
des victimes devraient victimes bien sûr
comme dans toutes ces infractions
absolument atroce il ya aussi la
question du dépérissement de la preuve
bien évidemment certains non bio un
certain nombre de très hauts magistrats
de ce pays se sont exprimés sur cette
question sont défavorables à
l'imprescriptibilité il ya aussi l'idée
même de ce qu'est la prescription
il a fallu des millénaires pour que
notre société civilisée envisage ce
qu'est la prescription
elle a aussi un certain nombre d'
avantages sociaux sociétaux qu'on ne
peut pas sous le coup de l'émotion
balayé d'un revers de manche
et puis enfin à briller attaqué me
disais à l'instant que certain nombre
d'associations sont contre l'
imprescriptibilité et que certains
psychiatres sont également contre l'
imprescriptibilité pour un tas de
raisons qui viennent notamment avec
beaucoup d'humanité d'être explicités
donc en la matière voyez vous rien n'est
simple
rien ne peut être manichéen tout doit
être extrêmement nuancé je suis
évidemment défavorable à tous ces
amendements visent la demande
explications de vote
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
l'enfant violet et seul terriblement
fondamentalement est irrémédiablement l'
atteinte à son intégrité comme on
l'appelle s'apparente à une amputation
c'est à dire quelque chose de définitif
violent et profondément destructeur
c'est une part de lui-même qu'on arrache
brutalité vécu dans une solitude infinie
c'est une forme de dissociation qui
permet à l'enfant de survivre une
adaptation naturel en somme lorsque les
violences s le cerveau est lessivé de
toutes races de souvenirs c'est se
répéter c'est fini c'est fini c'est fini
et oublié pendant des années un jour
cela remonte à la surface
violemment ou pas éventuellement
refoulée immédiatement loin dans un
brouillard d'oubli port d'attache des
enfants violés une pression s'installe
d'elle-même fermant la porte à toute
plainte dans un précipité de honte et de
peur car comment affronter les regards
et les jugements s'établit un
coffre-fort à côté de soi c'est un
cataclysme impossible a provoqué que de
parler c'est l'amputation psychologique
qui est là l'enfant ne peut pas parler
et le voudra qu'il ne le pourrait pas il
lui manque une perche qu'on pourrait lui
tendre et la plupart du temps il n'y a
pas de perches
voilà toute la particularité liée aux
crimes sexuels infligés par des adultes
qui sont des violeurs à des mineurs est
effectivement 30 ans ne suffit pas il ne
s'agit pas ici d'émotion comme cela a
été rappelé les faits hurle une fugue
petite fille sur cinq un garçon sur 13
sont cons se sont concernés et nous
avons devant nous quelque chose de
colossal l'empreinte délais
r une marque au fer rouge sur la société
toute entière celle d'une prédation
massive contre laquelle nous nous devons
de lutter sans tarder c'est notre
responsabilité aujourd'hui car c'est
l'impunité qui prévaut
ce sont les violeurs qui sont protégés
et c'est un problème
nous nous devons de protéger nos enfants
et nous devons donner aux victimes
quel que soit le moment où elles
pourront le faire la possibilité de
pouvoir porter plainte et d'avoir la
reconnaissance parce que c'est
nécessaire de l'état de victime je vous
remercie pas d'autre explication le voc
je vais mais pauvre voit ses amendements
pour les deux premiers identique un jour
appelle un avis favorable la commission
et un avis défavorable du gouvernement
quels sont ceux qui sont pour quels sont
ceux qui sont contre sont pas adoptées
pour l'amendement de madame millions 2
adjibi favorable également quels sont
ceux qui sont pour l heureux de toujours
après l'article 4 un amendement viennent
de rectifier madame rossignol je tiens à
préciser que c'est un moment n'est pas
un amendement de repli par rapport aux
votre précédent qui vient d'avoir lieu
que je n'ai pas voté les amendements en
faveur de l'imprescriptibilité et pour
autant avec mes collègues nous
présentons cet amendement là il consiste
à prévoir qu'en cas de pluralité de
victimes
quand certaines ne sont pas prescrites
et d'autres le sont les victimes la
prescription de puisse être suspendue
pour les victimes prescrite interrompu
merci marie pierre leca pression qui est
interrompue pour les victimes prescrite
c'est une question de justice c'est à
dire que dès lors qu'une procédure
judiciaire est en cours
que les victimes non prescrites peuvent
être partie civile
il serait intéressant que des victimes
prescrite puisse aussi l'être d'autant
que parfois c'est elle qu'on parlait en
premier c'est parce qu'elles ont parlé
que une enquête préliminaire a été
ouverte
et c'est cette enquête préliminaire qui
a permis d'identifier des victimes plus
récentes
donc c'est une mesure qui me paraît à la
fois ne pas porter atteinte au principe
de prescription qui est auquel sont très
attachés beaucoup de nos collègues et en
même temps de répondre à des situations
qui risquent d'être de plus en plus
fréquentes et des religions cet
amendement porte sur la question du
délai de prescription
il ne propose pas la prescriptive ilité
mais pourrait parfois quasiment aboutir
à ce résultat il s'agirait de prévoir
une interruption du délai de
prescription si l'auteur d'un crime sur
mineures comme est le même
rim sur un autre mineur cette
interruption ferait ensuite courir un
nouveau délai de prescription d'une
durée égale aux dés l'initiale soit en
l'occurrence trente ans un tel
dispositif pourrait donc avoir pour
effet de reporter le délai de
prescription 40 50 60 ans après la
commission du premier crime donc on peut
se demander si c'est vraiment opportun
compte tenu de la difficulté de
rapporter la preuve des faits après
l'écoulement d'un délai si long sur un
plan plus technique cet amendement
soulève plusieurs interrogations
si quelqu'un a commis un viol sur
mineure le délai de prescription
repartiraient de zéro si un nouveau viol
sur mineur et commis puisque c'est le
même crime mais pas si un autre crime
est commis peut-être plus grave encore
un assassinat d'enfants avec barbarie
etc
cette différence de traitement est
surprenante ensuite les éléments
générateurs serait la commission d'un
même crime
comment sait-on cas même crime et a été
commis seule une condamnation définitive
permettre de l'établir avec certitude
donc l'amendement pose un nouveau
problème réactionnelle même si on
comprend bien le but est l'intention de
notre collègue est tout à fait louable
donc au total nous considérons que le
délai de prescription de 30 ans à
compter de la majorité de la victime
adopté en 2018 est déjà très protecteur
et je crois qu'il est raisonnable de
conserver cette règle adoptée il ya
moins de trois ans lui du gouvernement
c'est une position de sagesse pour le
gouvernement la philosophie extrêmement
intéressante
on pense en revanche que les mécanismes
ne sont pas encore prêts mais
effectivement l'idée vous développez
vous faites bien de rappeler vous en
sais gré d'ailleurs que ce n'est pas un
amendement de retrait par rapport aux
précédents sont des choses bien
différentes
on connaît déjà quelques mécanismes un
peu analogue je pense notamment aux
connexité des quatre faits qui sont
commis trois sont à l'évidence prescrit
un n'est pas ils sont connexes et alors
on peut effectivement jugé les quatre
faits dont on connaît déjà un certain
nombre de deux comment dire et
d'exception sept règles sur la
prescription
moi je j'émets un avis de sagesse je
pense qu'il faut qu'on retravaille
encore mais que ça peut aller
effectivement dans le bon sens en tous
les cas c'est extrêmement intéressant
pour le gouvernement
adam de la gontrie oui président pour
indiquer pourquoi notre groupe
évidemment va voter cet amendement mais
insisté sur sur deux points c'est un
amendement très intéressant parce que je
le disais tout à l'heure dans mon
intervention lors de la discussion
générale c'est souvent la pluralité de
victimes qui permet de l'identifier et
de conforter l'accusation
on sait dans un domaine où la parole est
souvent mise en doute
ensuite indiqué au sénat que cet
amendement et la reprise mot pour mot
mot pour mot d'une disposition qui a été
voté par le sénat le 4 juillet 2018 par
avec un sous-amendement d'ailleurs de
madame mercier donc et qui avait disparu
par le miracle des commissions mixtes
paritaires nous connaissons tous cet
exercice donc ce n'est pas une invention
récente
et je rejoins tout à fait l'analyse de
garde concernant la note connexité enfin
bref ce que je veux dire c'est que ce
n'est pas une une innovation juridique
d'estimer qu on peut interrompre une
prescription dans un cas comme celui là
encore une fois c'est très intéressant
et ça peut répondre en partie aux
regrets on va dire de celles et ceux qui
souhaiteraient qu'on aille vers l'
imprescriptibilité dans ce domaine j'ai
le ministre
l'expérience que j'ai que j'ai rencontré
à de très nombreuses reprises c'est que
parfois quand il ya beaucoup de victimes
de viols et parfois c'est de l'ordre de
la vingtaine d'ailleurs tout est
prescrit s'offre une affaire alors on
ouvre le procès et les dix neuf autres
viennent témoigner naturellement elles
sont en élite et non pas témoin des
faits puisque les faits les faits qui
les concernent sont prescrits mais elles
sont en réalité témoin du comportement
et de la personnalité de l'accusé et
donc elle assiste au procès et ce n'est
pas l'heure d'une certaine façon et
disons le très clairement d'un point de
vue très pragmatique le juge
naturellement il ne juge pas de la même
façon en terme de gravité est sévérité
selon qu'il y a une seule victime ou une
victime et 19 autres dont tu qu'ils sont
pas qualifiés cités mais qui sont en
réalité victime donc là il ya aussi
quelque chose de très cohérent qui fait
qu' on peut vous suivre sur cette voie
et que on envisage bien sûr de le faire
pas d'autre explication je m voit cet
amendement quels sont ceux qui sont pour
qu'elle sorte que ceux qui sont contre
il est adopté
toujours après l'article 4 mamans meuf
rectifié madame boyer
oui merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues je vais allez vite vous
le savez depuis la loi perben le code de
procédure pénale prévoit qu une
correctionnalisation judiciaire peut
être décidée par la juridiction
d'instruction si la victime est
constituée partie civile
et si elle est assistée d'un avocat
lorsque ce renvoi est ordonnée en fait
le haut conseil et l'égalité entre les
hommes et des femmes constatent que le
viol est un crime qui constitue la plus
grave des violences sexuelles
or il fait trop souvent l'objet de
disqualification en agression sexuelle
consécutive d'un délit cette pratique
judiciaire de correctionnalisations des
viols et souvent justifiées pour des
motifs d'opportunités afin que l'
affaire soit jugée plus rapidement dans
les tribunaux correctionnels
de surcroît la raison moins avouable
elle permet le désengorgement des cours
d'assises
si la disqualification n'a pas pour but
de nuire aux intérêts des victimes qui
peuvent par ailleurs exposé de renvoi de
leur affaire devant le tribunal
elle minimise la gravité du viol et
remet en cause le principe de l'égalité
devant la justice et de nombreux
témoignages de femmes fortement
encouragés par leurs avocats et on peut
comprendre pourquoi à accepter cette
logique s'être laissé cette
qualification pardon le démontre
aujourd'hui ce que je souhaiterais c'est
que l'on mette fin à cette quasi
automaticité de la correctionnalisation
du viol et que le viol soit juin soit
jugé pour ce qu'il est c'est à dire un
crime aux yeux de la commission
oui merci monsieur faisant ma chère
collègue oui le viol est un crime le
viol est un crime doit être jugé comme
un crime je veux dire le viol n'est
jamais consenti on est tous d'accord là
dessus donc je comprends bien la tension
notre collègue mais cette mesure elle
est vraiment très technique
elle constitue donc une réponse au
phénomène de la correctionnalisation cas
des causes plus profondes notamment les
trop longs délais des délais tellement
look sept 7 ans avant d'être jugé ces
c'est insupportable donc je crois qu'il
fait aussi respectueux de la décision de
la victime puis comme c'est
correctionnalisé en génère
abondement de l'ami de la victime et qui
peut donc être compliqué de donner au
tribunal correctionnel
la possibilité de revenir sur les choix
arrêtés au cours de l'instruction
donc ce sont donc des mesures plus
structurelles qui peuvent permettre de
faire reculer la correctionnalisation
par exemple de leur déploiement de
secours criminel départemental qui sont
actuellement en cours d'expérimentation
et qui avait été créé pour ça à vis du
gouvernement
oui monsieur le président le premier
argument c'est qu'effectivement nous
avons une expérimentation des cours
criminelles
il faut qu'elles puissent se dérouler
deuxièmement et on va le dire la
correctionnalisation ce n'est pas du
tout ce que vous dites c'est pas vrai et
la correctionnalisation aux rockets
requiert a minima mais c'est bien la
moindre des choses
l'autorisation de la victime c'est fini
la à l'ailé l'un en mai on ne va pas en
correctionnelle sans avoir préalablement
recueillir l'assentiment de la victime
seulement des choses et troisièmement on
va se dire les choses
on ne peut pas parler comme ça au nom de
toutes les victimes
il ya des victimes j'en ai connu qui
préfèrent la correctionnelle parce que
c'est une épreuve la cour d'assises bon
donc il faut laisser aussi au parquet
beaucoup de souplesse sur ces questions
et ce n'est pas forcément des décisions
qui sont prises contre les victimes bien
au contraire et on se doit naturellement
d accompagner de recueillir leur
sentiment avant d'envisager la cour
d'assises c'est la cour d'assises c'est
quand même c'est quand même une épreuve
les publics il ya beaucoup de monde etc
on peut se demander un iphone enfin
c'est quand même autre chose qu'une
correctionnel il ya des victimes qui
préfèrent la correctionnalisation donc
de grâce au motif de vouloir aider les
victimes on peut parfois leur faire du
mal
le le victimaire ça n'est pas forcément
quelque chose qui va toujours dans le
bon sens il faut être raisonnable
le gouvernement est défavorable à cet
amendement
[Musique]
pas d'explications de vote je mets ou
voit cet amendement quels sont ceux qui
l'entourent quels sont ceux qui sont
contre qui s'obtiennent lille n'est pas
adopté un amendement 7 rectifié madame
boyer
quand même de prendre deux minutes pour
expliquer cet amendement et je voudrais
vous dire mes chers collègues que
lorsque j'ai visité le centre roumaine
sef avec le docteur pierre foldès et
frédéric mars
on m'a rappelé que faute de preuves
jugée suffisante éléments matériels tels
que les traces adn et témoignages sur
les aveux du mis en cause
près de cette plaine sur 10 pour
violences sexuelles sont classées sans
suite
mes chers collègues on ne peut pas d'un
côté constamment allonger les délais de
prescription notamment pour les mineurs
sans penser aux éléments matériels dans
certains cas les victimes portent
plainte des mois voire des années après
leur agression des éléments matériels
sont donc à l'heure actuelle impossible
à retrouver en droit pénal le doute
profite toujours à la cause et comme
nous le savons je vous invite à relire
l'excellent rapport du sénat de 2018
visant à prévenir et combattre les
violences faites aux femmes
on peut y lire que dans les umj le fait
de prélever l'adn pour le ressortir en
cas de plainte montrent que vous êtes
cru que pour les personnes qui se sont
rendues aux umj indépendamment d'une
plainte le taux de plaintes passé de 10
à 30% que cela permettra de conforter
leurs paroles quand elles seront prêtes
à porter plainte
d'ailleurs la gendarmerie nationale
souhaiterais que toutes les victimes
quel que soit le lieu où survient
l'agression sexuelle bénéficient d'un
accompagnement technique permettant
d'effectuer de recueillir avec diligence
les preuves matérielles de leur
agression le kit destiné aux enquêteurs
permettra de réaliser des prélèvements
de façon systématique encadre avec
d'agression sexuelle l'objet l'objectif
affiché est aussi de dissuader les
agresseurs potentiels qui courront alors
le risque d'être identifiés dans dans le
cas par exemple de relevés de traces adn
c'est pourquoi mes chers collègues suite
à mes nombreuses auditions je vous
propose d'améliorer le recueil des
preuves pour les mineurs victimes de
viol nous devons autorisées pour ces
victimes le prélèvement et la
conservation de tissus ou s'ils lui l'an
priori
ouf eto'o après une interruption de
grossesse dans la perspective d'une
procédure pénale ultérieure il ne s'agit
en aucun cas d'une incitation à porter
plainte mais de respecter la victime de
l'accompagner et de l'entourer de lui
laisser le choix
quoi qu'il arrive il ya une enquête le
dernier mot revient au juge
en aucun cas il ne s'agit de limiter le
recours à l'ivg et g ou de le détourner
mais de protéger encore plus la victime
je vous remercie
l'avis de la commission bon pour résumer
donc c'est un prélèvement sur les tissus
embryonnaires après ivg qui pose donc
des différents problèmes d'eau
cet amendement après une ivg réalisées
sur une jeune fille mineure dans le but
de réaliser des années génétique
permettant de confondre plus facilement
l'auteur d'un viol dans le cas où une
procédure judiciaire sera ouverte
après ultérieurement actuellement le
code de la santé publique d'autoriser
prélèvements qu'à des fins diagnostiques
thérapeutiques ou scientifiques
de plus un tel prélèvement ne peut avoir
lieu si la femme ayant subi les vg et
mineurs sauf s'il s'agit de rechercher
de rechercher la cause de l'ibg
l'amendement notre collègue de 4 d'une
double rupture par rapport aux principes
posés par le code de la santé publique
le prélèvement ne serait pas réalisé des
femmes médicales ou scientifiques et les
mineurs serait expressément concernés
donc ça fait 2-2 de raison en fait de
pas pouvoir le prendre
donc c'est difficile de cette fait sur
cette question délicate aux confins de
la bioéthique sans avoir sollicité
quelques avis extérieur je n'ai pas pu
faire d'auditionner dessus pour nous
éclairer notamment sur l'impact que
pourrait avoir une telle disposition sur
le recours à des fichiers ainsi sur le
risque des personnes se trouve accusé de
viol des années plus tard avec le risque
que l'analyse génétique va constituer un
premier élément mais qu'on pourra pas
retrouver s'il y avait eu consentement
ou pas puisque on sera des années des
années après donc je me demande en
particulier s'il ne serait pas opportun
d'encadrer un peu plus le dispositif en
le réservant à des situations qu'ils
laissent penser qu'une infraction a été
commise
donc après un dépôt de plainte faudrait
également analysé la la commission des
affaires sociales faire des recherches
en patates au détour d'un amendement il
me semble compliqué de donner un avis
favorable donc c'est un avis défavorable
à lui du gouvernement je suis évidemment
totalement défavorable à une espèce de
preuve par anticipation enfin mais
jusqu'où s'arrêteront
d'abord chronologiquement il faut qu'un
fai soient dénoncés une fois que le feu
ait dénoncé la police la justice parfois
directement se mettent en oeuvre il ya
là tout un mécanisme de recherche de la
preuve
bon mais par anticipation joint
difficilement comment ton pourrait
conserver au fond la preuve d'un crime
qui ne sera peut-être jamais dénoncés et
qui peut être n'a pas existé je trouve
ça assez curieux c'est contraire me
semble-t-il à l'ordre des choses
véritablement et là c'est la
démonstration de ce que pour bien faire
au fond parce que l'idée est bonne je je
je l'entends on va beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup trop loin il faut être très
circonspect avec ces choses nous avons
un certain nombre de principes que notre
société civilisée a mis des millénaires
à élaborer on ne peut pas les balayer au
nom de l'émotion et de et d'une
efficacité et d'une efficacité pardon
fonds voudrait maximale tout ça me
paraît dangereux retrait ou ou
défavorables on ne peut pas préparer
surtout dans ces conditions d'ailleurs
des preuves éventuellement à venir c'est
le président mes chers collègues on n'a
pas le temps de débattre mais je
voudrais simplement dire à monsieur le
ministre je je comprends ce qu'il dit
mais je ne peux pas l'admettre dans le
cas précis qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
parce que justement plusieurs années
après puisqu'on a rallongé la presse l'
imprescriptibilité là la victime fait
état de faits qui se sont produits au
moment où ils se sont produits elle ne
pouvait pas déposé plainte
là nous avons il y aura une enquête y
aura des auditions il y aura exactement
la même chose mais il y aura la
possibilité d'avoir une preuve et je me
permets d'insister pour vous dire que
cette demande elle ne m'est pas venu
tout tout à coup un jour comme ça c'est
parce que j'ai rencontré de nombreuses
associations notamment celles qui
s'occupent des mineurs et
des femmes les plus en difficulté et
qu'ils ont besoin de cela donc je pense
qu'il faut retravailler sur cette
question et comme l'a dit madame mercier
probablement faire en sorte que le code
de la santé publique soit lui aussi
amélioré pour qu'on puisse protéger les
victimes et recueillir des éléments de
preuve
je vais mettre aux voix cet amendement
quels sont ceux qui sont pour
quels sont ceux qui sont contre qui
s'abstiennent ramadan n'est pas adopté
je me revois l'article 5
quels sont ceux qui sont pour donc
qu'ils s'abstiennent antique est adopté
je mets ou voir l'article 6 quels sont
ceux qui sont pour contre sorcières
l'arctique est adoptée alors cycle
sceptre un amendement 28 présenté par
madame merci au nom de la commission des
lois
je suis prise de supprimer une référence
une disposition superfétatoire du
gouvernement je mettre aux voix quels
sont ceux qui sont pour contre
ils s'abstiennent l'adopter
je me vois leur cycle sept nouveaux
quels sont ceux qui sont pour compte qui
s'oxyde m l'arctique est adoptée après
l'article
c'est un amendement 23 présenté par
madame meunier
merci monsieur le président pour aller
très vite je présentais si vous le
voulez à la suite 23 et 24 ils sont liés
à l'obligation de signalement c'est un
sujet qu'on connaît le sénat a déjà voté
à la loi de juillet 2018 cette
disposition et cela a disparu
avec la majorité présidentielle qui l'a
fait disparaître en cmp obligation de
signalement et son corollaire protection
et non poursuite de celui ou de celle
qui signale nous savons qu'en l'état
actuel de la législation et des codes de
déontologie médicale il n'y a pas
d'obligation de signaler il y a
seulement un risque lié à la non
dénonciation et la confusion persistera
tant que cette obligation ne figurera
pas noir sur blanc dans la loi
donc voilà centraux développer parce que
je sais qu'après il y à un autre texte
je vous demande donc de voter ces
obligations mission donc sur ce deux
amendements
on a beaucoup travaillé le sujet sur
l'obligation de signalement avec
catherine de roche michel meunier maryse
carrère
c'est un avis défavorable on peut on
vous ne refera pas les débats mais en
soit on n'a pas le temps mais c'est le
secret professionnel qui est quelque
chose pour moi d'absolument intangible
voilà à vis à vis du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président ce sera
aussi un avis défavorable sur replonger
juste très brièvement quelques mois en
arrière lors des débats sur la loi du 30
juillet 2020 qui a modifié l'article 226
4-14 du code pénal afin d'aligner les
règles relatives au signalement des
violences au sein du couple avec celles
qui étaient déjà applicables au
signalement des sévices commis sur les
enfants est désormais dans les deux cas
les professionnels de santé peuvent
signaler c'est ces faits au procureur de
la république sans devoir recevoir
l'accord de la victime ce qui était le
cas s'agissant des violences conjugales
préalablement et l'objectif de
l'amendement que vous nous on veut nous
présenter je parle du premier du 23
madame la sénatrice se baigner les
médecins seraient désormais tenus de
signaler au procureur alors pour trois
raisons nous sommes opposés
effectivement à cet amendement des
raisons d'ordre opérationnel des raisons
de fond et puis des raisons un peu de
formalisme réseau opérationnel
modification qui nous paraît excessive
dans la mesure où très concrètement des
parents face à cette obligation faite
aux médecins pourraient être amenés à ne
pas à ne plus conduire leurs enfants
chez le médecin par ailleurs il ya une
réalité qui est qu'aujourd'hui dans
notre pays les médecins ne signale ne
procède à des informations préoccupantes
tout type de violence confondues qu'à
hauteur de 6% ce qui est très très
faible alors qu'il voit beaucoup de nos
enfants passaient devant re et qu' ils
détectent probablement a suffisamment
qu'après vraiment un enjeu de formation
mais il ya aussi un enjeu d'isolement
des médecins et d'un certain nombre de
professionnels de santé face à ces
situations qui sont compliqués qui sont
difficiles quand vous êtes le médecin de
famille depuis vous avez deux trois
générations vous pouvez être pris dans
un espèce de conflits je porte pas de
jugement là dessus je pense que tout le
monde doit évidemment dénoncé les faits
qu'il soupçonne mais il ya une forme
d'isolement des professionnels de santé
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans le
cas du plan de 2010 9 novembre 2019 que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure nous avons
prévu de créer des référents pédiatrique
dans chacune et je me dépêche mesdames
les sénatrices dans chacune de ces
unités d'accueil pédiatrique enfants en
danger que j'évoquais pour que les
médecins puissent avoir une ressource
qu'ils puissent appeler qu'il puisse
renvoyer éventuellement vers ces
professionnels de santé formés
spécialisés quand ils sont face à cette
situation il avait sa matière d'art pour
toutes ces raisons et je passe donc sur
raison de formalisme c'est que ce n'est
pas placé au bon endroit mais ces dunes
l'avis défavorable je vais mettre voir
l'amendement 23 quels sont ceux qui sont
pour quels sont ceux qui sont contre qui
s'abstiennent
il n'est pas adopté l'amendement 24
quels sont ceux qui sont pour quels sont
ceux qui sont contre qui s'abstiennent
pas adapté à l'article 8 je suis saisi
d'une demande de parole madame valérie
boyer je vais mettre aux voix l'article
quels sont ceux qui sont pour contre
socke sienne articles 8 et adopté un
amendement
mero 16 présenté par madame à se créer
très rapidement parce que je connais le
sort de cet amendement mais sa tion
perdu d'avancé les batailles qu'on ne
livre pas mais comme il faut aller vite
je vous renvoie à l'objet de cet
amendement qui explique les raisons pour
lesquelles nous souhaitions modifié
l'intitulé de cette proposition de loi
en vue de la commission c'est un avis
négatif parce que nous gardons le titre
de madame billaut et que nous avons
enrichi la ppl d'un aveu d'un aspect
préventif
donc avis défavorable à vis du
gouvernement
les favorable pour les mêmes raisons pas
d'explications de vote que m madame de
la gontrie pardon
je vous remercie de votre accueil chers
collègues sur ce texte important dire
que évidemment ce texte est une avancée
non on est bien sûr le jeu voit
explications de vote sur l'ensemble
voyage aller plus vite
plaignez vous
on est sur l'amendement 16 donc je vais
procéder au vote sur l'amendement 16 pas
sur l'ensemble du texte
quels sont ceux qui sont pour
quels sont ceux qui sont contre
l'amendement n'est pas adopté là je vais
passer maintenant
à l'ensemble de la proposition de loi il
attire des explications de vote
madame de la ganterie tout maintenant
sur le texte j'indiquais donc que ce
texte était une avancée
évidemment nous avons au cours de ces
débats aujourd'hui fait encore des
commandes ird et nous n'avons nous avons
délibéré sur des propositions qui ont
renforcé les choses et notamment à
l'instant sur l'interruption de la
prescription peu accueillant cas de
pluralité de victimes
nous avons amélioré les dispositions
concernant la prescription
en cas de non dénonciation nous avons
progressé concernant l'inceste en cas
d'atteinte sexuelle mais vous le
comprenez bien un regret important sur
votre refus de voter la criminalisation
avec cette nouvelle infraction de de
l'inceste sur mineurs
pour autant ce texte est important même
si sur certains aspects nous trouvons
insuffisant et comme je l'indiquais en
discussion générale notre groupe votera
favorablement cette proposition de loi
merci monsieur le président évidemment
je ne fais pas rallonger les débats
évident
ce texte est comme l'a dit notre
collègue marie pierre de la gontrie une
avancée certaine dans le sens de d'une
meilleure protection des jeunes mineurs
je tiens à remercier le président de la
commission des lois est là et la
rapporteure pour l'excellent travail
qu'ils ont menées sur ce texte ainsi que
tous les sénateurs qui ont amendé le
texte dans un souci de précision et
d'amélioration du texte
je vais m'arrêter là au niveau des
remerciements remercié le président
marseille et le groupe union centriste
qui a eu le courage d'inscrire un sujet
compliqué à l'ordre du jour du sénat
merci madame rossignol
merci monsieur le président je me marie
pierre de la gontrie la diane il ya un
instant notre groupe votera le texte et
moi comme le groupe
je voudrais simplement faire de remarque
la première c'est que je suis perplexe
pour nous sur la politique des petits
pas en ce qui concerne ces sujets je
trouve que nous sommes de texte en texte
à chaque fois un peu crue d'une prudence
exagérée d'autant que le temps passant
on se rend compte que ce qu'on a eu son
temps à discuter deux ans avant était en
fin de compte adapter des dés le moment
on en a parlé mais c'est pas le preuve
le premier le point principal de mon
sujet je m'adresse particulièrement
adrien taquet que le garde n'en prennent
pas ombrage pour dire qu' il ne faut pas
dans ces affaires surestimé le droit et
le code pénal la lutte contre l'inceste
n'est pas qu'une affaire judiciaire
n'est pas qu'une affaire de code pénal
c'est avant tout une affaire de
prévention d'évolution de notre
civilisation et d'accompagnement
médico-social
je dis ça parce que il ya des débats sur
la prescription je ne suis pas sûr que
la prescription soit le principal
adversaire des victimes
le principal adversaire des victimes
c'est d'une part le silence de ceux qui
savent et d'autre part la cécité de ceux
qui pourraient savoir et comment
allons-nous accompagnés dès aujourd'hui
des victimes
je vais donner un exemple souvent les
enfants victimes d'inceste sont replacés
à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
savez vous mes chers collègues adrien
taquet le sait combien il ya de place en
france à l'aise est dédié aux enfants
aux jeunes filles victimes d'inceste
25-25 place pour accompagner prendre en
charge un traumatisme spécifiques qui
nécessitent un accompagnement spécifique
savez vous combien il ya de place pour
les garçons victimes d'inceste 00 place
pour les garçons victimes d'inceste
donc la priorité maintenant que nous
avons décelé du code pénal c'est que le
gouvernement propose au département de
mettre en place un accueil spécifique
pour les victimes d'inceste que ce qui
existe une dans un établissement une
mexes en france par un accueil des
jeunes filles victimes d'inceste c'est
que s'il y en ait dans toutes les
régions et que nous puissions
accompagner ce traumatisme à la hauteur
de ce qu'il a été pour permettre aux
victimes de se reconstruire le plus
difficile n'est pas de modifier le code
pénal le code dit fut le plus difficile
c'est d'accompagner les victimes
le shbo y sont en quatre mots monsieur
le président d'abord une vraie avancée
consensus entre les groupes
un texte qui a progressé en première
lecture un garde des sceaux qui nous a
promis une navette fructueuse nous a
écoutés tout en défendant ses des grands
principes du droit
il est là pour cela et un grand merci à
nos clients je vais essayer d'être aussi
concise que mon collègue vient de le
faire mais moi je me réjouis du débat
qu'on a eu dans cet hémicycle sur un
temps contraint et ça je trouve que les
niches nous laisse toujours un goût amer
parce qu'on a envie de te parler
d'avantagé et d'aborder toutes toutes
les propositions de loi mais je me
réjouis du débat qui a été très
respectueux et je trouve qu'il ya un
cheminement dans tous les rangs par
rapport aux violences faites aux enfants
et aux mineurs donc c'est un pas positif
en avançant chemine et on bouge à
l'intérieur de nos propres groupes en
écoutant les arguments des uns et des
autres et l'argument un grand merci à
marie mercier un ebe ion est aussi au
garde des sceaux qui a su nous nous
aider aussi à progresser donc c'est ce
que je voulais dire
nous avons eu aussi des auditions nous
et on a essayé d'avancer sur la
présomption de contraintes qui n'est pas
pour nous une présomption de culpabilité
c'est quelque chose d'intéressant avec
un juge qui nous a éclairés qui
s'appelle edward durant et qui est un
grand professionnel plein d'humanisme
que tout le monde connaît ici je pense
qu'il va falloir qu'on continue à
acheminer et je voudrais quand même
signaler que parmi
donc les plaintes pour viol 70% des
plaintes sont classées sans suite
soixante pour cent des enfants des
victimes pardon sont des mineurs 30% au
moins de 11 ans nous avons encore à
faire progresser la loi pour les
protéger et c'est ce que nous c'est ce à
quoi nous aspirons tous en tout cas si
le positionnement aussi notre groupe
vous l'aurez compris merci monsieur le
président je voudrais d'abord remercier
l'auteur de cette ppl mode en billons
ainsi que la rapporteure et tous mes
collègues parce que nous avons assisté
aujourd'hui à débattre en groupe ce qui
est très important et en même temps nous
avons vu les aspects qui reste encore à
faire évoluer donc c'est ça c'est un
problème qui reste tout à fait actuel
comme nous l'avons vu ces derniers temps
et que il faut probablement s'atteler à
la formation des juges pour que pour que
les choses ne frappe pas à leur
vigilance et que les femmes qui ont subi
ces atrocités soi disant soit remise
devant et devant la conscience des juges
est que ces femmes puissent pas oublié
mais avancer avancer dans la vie il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire au niveau de
la justice et je compte sur notre garde
des sceaux est pour faire avancer aussi
cette formation des juges pour qu'ils ne
restent pas insensibles à ces questions
dans l'avenir merci j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
de lyon centre-est sur l'ensemble du
texte
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
jeudi plus que 1 190 à voter le scrutin
est clos
d'accord
voici le résultat du scrutin sur
l'ensemble du texte compte tenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordés par les sénateurs au groupe
politique est notifiée à la présidence
nombre de votants 345 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 343 pour l'adoption
343 contre 0 le sénat a adopté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]